this is Jocko podcast number 219 with
echo Charles and me Jocko willing
good evening echo good evening the train
station is very busy tata says the train
cars they are using are called cattle
cars which are usually used to transport
animals or dry goods every day more
cattle cars arrive and get filled
completely as each train leaves
I wonder where is going and hope it is
somewhere wonderful when our name is
finally called it is our turn to load up
on the train we are packed in like
preserved pickles in a jar once the car
is filled with sixty to eighty people
they lock the doors the car has no seats
or toilets and no water there are small
openings at the top of the car to
provide air but only those tall enough
can see out and the openings do not
provide enough ventilation I am not tall
enough to see out so I have no idea
where we are or where we are headed it
is colder than usual this April and hard
to stay warm even packed together like
sardines the Train does not stop for any
reason
so we ride and ride for a few days
standing all the while mama on Lee and
Tata tried to comfort us children even
though I feel overwhelmed I try not to
cry or complain I want to show mama and
Tata that I am big girl now
a group
man read their Bibles and quietly recite
prayers the cars get stinky because of
the poor ventilation and no toilets I
don't understand why we are treated this
way the looks of panic on the faces of
the adults and the cries of the younger
children unsettle me at long last the
train finally slows down and comes to a
stop the door is unlocked and a man in a
blue and white uniform climbs into our
cattle car and tells us we are in
Auschwitz Poland
ouch wits and I don't know if there is a
name in the world that conjures up more
vile and a more evil part of human
nature than ash words ash wits was a
concentration camp in Poland established
and operated by the Nazis who occupied
Poland at the time it had been a Polish
army barracks but the Nazis converted it
into a prison initially it was used for
political prisoners and the camp quickly
became a sadistic nightmare and in the
five years that it was functioning 1.3
million people were sent there and 1.1
million of those died
and that number includes 15,000 Soviet
prisoners of war it includes 21,000
Romani people it includes 74,000 Polish
people and it includes 960,000 Jews 865
thousand of whom were sent to the gas
chambers and murdered immediately upon
their arrival at Auschwitz and many of
those who were not gassed died of
disease of starvation of exhaustion of
vicious beatings of medical experiments
or of just individual executions
unspeakable horror worse than you can
even imagine an actual hell on earth
created by people
but in that nightmare in that evil story
of sadism and anguish and torment there
are also stories of Hope stories of
sacrifice stories of love and stories of
survival and it is an honor to be able
to share one of those stories with you
today the opening that I read is from a
book called - who survived keeping hope
alive while surviving the Holocaust the
story of rose and Max Schindler which
was documented by Emily Connelly and it
is an honor to have Rose Schindler with
us here today to share her story Rose
welcome and thank you so much for coming
on I wanted to say it's a tremendous
thing that you're doing okay because
there are so many people that have no
idea what happened to us during the war
so thank you very much for doing this
well I hope we can share and educate
people on on what you went through on
what your family went through on and on
what happened to millions millions of
people and you know I got lucky
because you were doing a speech here in
San Diego and my wife went to see you
and my wife came home and said darling
you have to get this woman on your
podcast and immediately she no she told
me and we were able to connect through
your son Ben so you know she brought
home the book I read the book in a day
and just tried to make this happen as
quickly as possible so so thank you for
coming in and like I said the name of
the book is
- who survived and as I always have to
tell people on the podcast
I don't not gonna read the whole book
you can order the book and we'll put our
word at the end of how to do that but
you have to get this book to get the
whole picture we'll go through some of
the some of the points of it today but
it's a phenomenal book it reads very
easily it's it's it the language is
great it's it sounds like you read it
like you're telling a story which is
exactly what it sounds like that's how
it's written that's how it comes across
and so the book is called - who survived
and I'll jump into reading some of it
right now okay my name is Rosie Schwartz
I'm 8 years old and in third grade I
like to tell stories I was born on
December 28 1929 the fourth child and a
family of six girls and two boys how you
solder is 15 you ki is 13 and they're
their names the English names is Helen
and Judy fishel or Phillip is 1110 Chu
is five blim Chu is three Fei is two and
mire bear is just a baby
Mama's name is Regina or rifka and Tatas
name is Solomon not all families have
eight kids but many do my family lives
in Czechoslovakia and we learn to speak
Czech in school mom and taught I learned
Hungarian in school when they were my
age after World War one in 1918 the
government changed from austro-hungarian
Empire to the Democratic Czechoslovakia
sometimes when the government changes
the official language changes - that is
when our language changed from Hungarian
to check since now it's 1937 it's been
almost 20 years in Tata says everyone is
used to speaking Czech so what so what
language were you speaking at home at
this time
Yiddish Yiddish and that's why you got
the Yiddish names right trying to get
trying to force me to try and say
Yiddish names which I'm not great at I
well you're not perfect but you're great
okay I'll take that and eight eight
people in the family or is that eight
kids right eight kids ten people in the
family and you say that's my parents say
the Czech government is good to us
everyone has equal rights and my family
does all we can to be good citizens
neighbors help each other and are always
friendly we speak Hungarian check with
our friends Ukrainian is also a similar
language and is spoken by many because
we are Jewish we speak Yiddish the
language of our faith at home my father
sister aunt Li am I saying that right
yes aunt Li lives with us her husband
died in the first world war when her son
was only 17 years old and he decided to
move to the Holy Land leaving her by
herself now what's interesting about
this is I'm assuming that he fought her
her husband fought and died in the First
World War
right I'm assuming he fought for Hungary
which was aligned with Germany right
absolutely it was austria-hungary before
the first day there was a hundred
thousand German Jews who served on the
side of the Germans in World War one
there was 12,000 German Jews who were
killed in World War one fighting on the
side of the Germans and there was 18,000
German Jews that were awarded the Iron
Cross in World War two I didn't know
that mnsure you know the reason that I
thought and I had heard that before like
I told you before we started I study war
a lot and I read a lot about war and to
me you know you sometimes you hear oh
the the anti-semitism is this
long-standing thing that everybody knew
about for a really long time and yet you
this is only 20 years prior you had a
hundred thousand Jews that were fighting
on the side of the Germans just like
everybody else
yeah and that's how quickly things can
change if we're
yes unfortunately yes you go on here
since she was alone
my parents invited her to live with our
family aunt Lee is a seamstress so she
sells all our clothes when one girl
grows out of a dress that goes to the
next sister to use we call these
hand-me-downs we're gonna head out Lee
lives with us because she is a friend
with mama and helps take care of the
kids
mama thoughts are raising us as Orthodox
Jews and we follow the rules faithfully
we always eat foods that are especially
prepared to honor Jewish dietary laws
called kosher each week we celebrate
Shabbat on Friday night before the holy
day on Saturday we attend synagogue we
believe strongly that God will protect
us from anything bad our code of conduct
says that the way we act in life is how
we show our faith
now that sounds good except for I got to
this part that says I do not like
homework we have to do every evening I
have three more years of school before
I'm done I think I'll learn to be a
seamstress seamstress when I grow up so
I can sew clothes for my family we have
a comfortable three room house on Main
Street our kitchens the largest room of
all the kitchen oven is so big that I
could lie down inside of it if I wanted
to one of my favorite things mama breaks
is rye bread when mama allows us to have
some of the warm bread with melting
butter on it I am the happiest girl
anywhere mama is strict with us so we
learned how to live good Jewish life but
she's also loving even when her mama
scolds me I know she is teaching me how
to be good I want to be like mama when I
grow up because our family has many
children every room in our house has
been the bed in the kitchen is at the
far end near the pantry that this is
where my two brothers official and Meir
bear sleep the living room has two beds
where all six of us girls sleep I sleep
with you convey in one bed I don't mind
because I am small and there's enough
room Fanny Fanny it's a big girl to
sleep next to her because she gets
scared easily hi Sara
sleeps with peh-chu and glim true so you
guys are you guys are making good use of
the real estate yeah yeah this and again
I'm skipping through
a bunch of this book so people can read
it on their own but really it just is
such a it paints a very kind of idyllic
picture of this beautiful family all
living this you know nice quaint life
you stay here every night we light the
house with kerosene lanterns that give
the house of gold and glow and a special
smell
we are cozy and warm in the house on the
cold winter nights our water pump is a
modern metal hand pump that pumps water
up to the spigot every time you push the
handle down this is a modern invention
you're talking about there right because
you mentioned some of the other family
still had the bucket that you're drawing
well we had a well in the other house
yes
so I mean anytime we needed water we
take go to the well and let it down and
then we bring it up and that's how we
had big that got the water you continue
on here we have plenty to eat each day
most of it grows on our farm all of us
kids help momma manage the animals and
the vegetables mama says our farm is one
acre but it feels as big to me as a
whole meadow I help tend to the garden
and collect eggs our garden needs
attention nearly every day in the spring
and summer to keep the weeds away and
the vegetables picked as they ripen we
also have chicken cows and geese so it's
the is is the farm located on your house
and main street or is it somewhere else
oh no it's right there it's right there
but we also have a lot of land out of
the out of the village like maybe a
couple of miles away sure okay but it's
we throw the wheat and the corn and I
don't know what else but all the bread
that we ate came from the wheat okay so
we do not have enough room to the area
where we lived so we had additional land
out of the village and that's where they
used to crawl the corn and the wheat got
it you say this Tata
says the bar mitzvah is simple but it
changes everything
he becomes a man and may in turn learn a
trade or may and may in turn to learn a
trade once he completes his internship
he begins to work girls don't have a Bar
Mitzvah but they do sometimes learn a
trade when they finish school after
sixth grade many girls become
seamstresses because knowing how to sew
for a family is important
most girls marry by the time they are 18
or 20 with the help of a matchmaker
girls plan to get married and become a
mother so learning a trade is less
important for them so is that where you
saw your life going rank just you'll 18
or 19 or 20 you'll get the matchmaker
will come along right give you a match
just did this wouldn't work with my
daughters I'll tell you that's how life
was in those days simple but it was
great yeah till the war broke out yeah
yeah the I mean again this this really
idyllic picture even though our village
isn't very big it has nearly everything
we need when I walked down the street
many people I see are Jewish mama says
there are about 2,000 people in Cerdan
how do you say the name of the Fettig
yeah said ed yeah I would I'm going to
try that one again
well it's s er D and E it's right
between montage and Anwar and this is a
pretty rural place yes we I don't think
I don't know how many people we had
there but I don't think we had more than
between 1,500 and maybe I don't think we
had 2,000 people there but the next
towns on either side of us they had like
20 to 25,000 people in each like Czech
Slovak
I mean hung excuse me Oliver and moon
Koch okay and they were about half an
hour away is that right um well it was
it was I would say 20 miles on either
side but that was the insanity means
middle so if anybody wanted to go from
Saraya to montage or over you know it
was like about 20 miles but if anybody
wanted to go from Malaysia to where they
had to go through saranya that was the
only road
over there you guys also had a pharmacy
a dressmaker a fabric store a cabinet
maker a plant pots and pans maker
we can either buy new pots and pans or
get your old ones or there's an open
market farmers market farmers market
middle of the city town you said you had
an uncle that lived in the states that
sometimes sent you things right and you
were pretty proud to have have things
from America right it was exciting
they said we didn't have unfortunately
when I never met my uncle okay we came
to this country and he he didn't want to
know us I don't know why he when we came
to the United States the Jewish
organization was involved in that okay
even though my husband's family sent us
epidemics to come to America but still
the Jewish organizations needed to know
who's coming what's coming and
everything else so they asked me do I
have any relatives from my side of the
family not mex aside I said yes I have
an uncle who lives in McKeesport and my
mother's brother okay and we used to
actually correspond with him from when
we lived in Europe and so and when we
came to America I even tried to be try
to be in touch and we actually we did
spoke on the phone sometime or
correspondent but he never invited us to
come to meet them we lived in New York
we came to New York in 1951 and so the
first year wasn't too easy but after one
year we found my husband's uncle had an
apartment house so we got a two-bedroom
apartment house which was great in those
days and and I used to write to them I
have room you could come and stay with
me
you know we'd love to meet you they
never invited us so we never met them
well let's you mentioned your husband
let's jump in a max a little bit Frank
because
you you both wrote this poem you both
you both have both your stories kind of
how you started separately and then
eventually you get together but max
gives his kind of childhood which was
which is certainly different than yours
right it's pretty it comes pretty clear
that you were a country girl and he was
a city absolutely so he says my name is
max Schindler I was born on June 18th
1929 and I'm 8 years old my family lives
in cottbus am I saying that right right
caught bus German canvas caught bus
Germany which is south of Berlin dad
says this is a big city with 55,000
people we live in a multi-story
apartment building that is filled with
families that is why there are so many
boys to play with after school every day
dad knows so many good people and has
friends everywhere sometimes he goes out
to play cards with his friends but
otherwise he is at home with us every
night my parents tell us they have come
a long way in life they are both
originally from Poland and speak Polish
fluently they met fell in love and
married in Poland however they wanted
more than their farm life and developed
a plan to moved to Germany they speak
German well and enjoy the modern life
and progressive teachings of Germany dad
said it was important to them to move to
the city before having kids so they did
just that
dad says Germany is known for his for
its advanced knowledge in science
innovative ways to get information to
everyone quickly and new ways to produce
things he says Germany is the place to
get the best education so we will have
the most opportunities in life my dad
mom and dad really like Germany and
again this is just you know this is this
is what 19 1937 right and totally having
a great life in Germany yes he says my
dad Benjamin is one of nine children he
says his family is very religious
following all the Jewish laws about how
to live therefore he is the one who
teaches us about our religion dad says
he's pleased to see how we are growing
up he is more relaxed than his other
family members about our faith and likes
to say we are German first and Jewish
second
that had fewer business opportunities in
Poland but he found a good business in
Germany he runs a wine and liquor store
he makes enough money for us to live in
our large apartment and have a maid our
apartment is filled with new furniture
furniture and fancy carvings so he's
doing pretty good right the Schindler's
yes yes every Friday night we attend
Shabbat services at the synagogue there
aren't a lot of Jews in my neighborhood
or apartment building but there are
plenty at the synagogue many of our
friends go to churches in town
no one cares which faiths other people
practice it seems like families only
talk about their faith at home so again
you know I had to mention that because
religion wasn't at the forefront of
people's minds it's it and they're
thinking about it so that's what that's
that's kind of the opening of the book
and again I skipped through a bunch of
it and but it kind of lays out you know
the the country girl and the and the
city boy right but the you know I
thought that it was important to point
out both of you
living very nice comfortable enjoyable
lives in these in these different areas
yes yes the next chapter is called winds
of change unfortunately
so you say life is changing I don't like
fourth grade as much as third grade it
is harder than last year and other kids
won't help me so far 1938 is not my best
year I don't understand why but some of
my friends are not talking to me as much
as they used to some have even started
ignoring me
I find myself mostly talking to my
Jewish friends so this is 1938 right and
you're starting to even as a kid even as
a as a fourth grader you're realizing
that some of the kids that would talk to
you before all of a sudden they're not
talking anymore
all of a sudden we don't have the rights
anymore so many things are changing
daily unbelievable
I'm gonna fast forward a little bit
within a few weeks on the way home from
school
I see soldiers in the village I've never
seen soldiers before and I smile and
wave at them as I walk toward our house
none of the soldiers wave back at me and
suddenly I feel scared when I get home I
asked mama and Tata why the soldiers
have come to sarahdan yay
did I get it said yeah yeah pretty good
they tell us the soldiers are Hungarians
and they are here to take over tata says
there may be changes coming but we are
not to worry
after a few weeks I realized Tatas right
many things are changing now with the
Hungarians arrival and none of them none
of the changes are good no one knows
what is happening yet no one resists
when I asked Tata why no one does
anything he says that we have to follow
the rules and be good citizens this
doesn't quite make sense to me but he
explains that I will understand more
when I'm older so even even you're
you're I guess you're nine years old and
when you see the Hungarians show up and
you see this kind of intimidation
starting even you think hey why aren't
we saying anything well you know
sometimes the less you say is better and
if you complain too much you might get
into trouble that's another thing all of
a sudden we don't have the rights like
we used to before we were practically
the leaders of the village the Jewish
people because they were all in business
and mostly on the farm their non-jewish
people were mostly farmers and we got
along very well we had no problems at
all you continue on now the adults seem
frightened when I go into the village in
town all the adults huddled together in
small groups i watch as they cautiously
look over their shoulders before
whispering together for several minutes
no one smiles and waves to me as they
usually did this puzzles me but I
figured it has something to do with the
fact that everyone becomes nervous when
a Hungarian soldier walks by I also
notice
that people who go to our synagogue no
longer talk with people that are not
Jewish
I don't understand why because until
things started to change everyone had
been nice to one another when I visit
Tata at a shop I only see Jewish
customers Tata had made suits for
everyone so it seemed strange to me
Tata says not to worry about it Tata
also says that everyone is nervous about
what the change to Hungarian rule will
mean for our village over the next few
weeks the Hungarians make many changes
the biggest changes for us kids is that
all Jews are not allowed to go to our
public school and we must be inside our
homes by 6:00 p.m. and the evenings they
call this a curfew it makes me sad
because I like to play outside until the
Sun sets and Mama calls us in for dinner
the neighborhood kids have become mean
to us throwing rocks and calling us
names like dirty Jew good fortunately
one day when I'm walking and talking
with Yuki a boy calls us from across the
street
stop laughing and behave yourself you
you dirty Jews he yells as he picks up a
rock I will hurt you if you don't so
though the kids everyone yeah
into September 1939 and I'm nearly 10
years old I don't like the new Hungarian
rules but we are doing fine and staying
at home with Mama
I don't miss going to school at all
tonight Tata has a strange look on his
face when he walks in the house he looks
pale and is pacing back and forth he
seems to be having trouble saying what
he means then he tells mama that his
shop and everything in it are gone gone
what do you mean mama asks her eyes
getting big I can see your hands start
to shake as she suddenly sits down
heavily on one of the kitchen chairs I
was cutting fabric when three Hungarian
soldiers walked into the shop they
approached me and told me that all of us
have to leave they said that all Jewish
businesses now belong to them and that
we too were to leave and never to return
Toth has voice shakes he too sits down
on the chair running his hands through
his hair so now this is sort of a
transition from hey they're putting some
rules on you but now all of a sudden
they're taking property noodles every
day every day they had noodles right
thank God they didn't take our homes
away that's one thing the businesses
were all taken away and did that happen
like to everyone in the town at the same
time all the Jewish businesses were
taken away yes
you continue on you say life is not
normal at all news has spread that
Germany is at war with Poland no one
knows what will come next
now we we're gonna witness now max go
through the same kind of similar
transition right this is max it's the
fall of 1937 now and after just a few
weeks back at home from a relaxing
summer at Grandma Swedes farm I realized
that something is very different it's
not just nerves about returning to
school
the adults are whispering in the grocery
store lines while washing laundry in the
basement and at dads store even mom and
dad wait for us to leave the room to
talk something is not right I know fred
senses it as well so we asked mom and
dad what is going on it seems there is
growing concern about Adolf Hitler who
has a hatred for all Jews and that
there's a possibility for war one day
dad comes home from work to tell us that
there are yellow Jewish stars and signs
painted on the windows of his store that
say udin rouse meaning Jews get out of
here fast forward a little bit the next
day dad informs us that the Germans came
to his liquor store and took all its
contents he was ordered not to return
Fred and I are jumping up and yelling
they can't do that he orders us to sit
down and listen he continues saying that
throughout the ordeal people were
throwing rocks and calling him a dirty
Jew he had no choice but to walk away
dad wants us to understand that we are
in no position to resist the Germans
doing so could have serious consequences
he will now become a traveling liquor
salesman and you go on or sorry max goes
on dad continues to try and move the
paperwork along for immigration of the
US so he had he had realized we gotta
get out of here and he starts putting
through the paperwork to get out of
Germany and get to the US and it's it's
taking it's taken a lot of time it's a
bureaucracy said you see max says here
dad is even more eager now to get us out
of Germany he has completed the
paperwork for the entire family to move
to the United States with
help of his relatives in San Francisco
even with their help there are many
hurdles to jump the paper takes longer
than dad thinks they should so he is
anxious although is nothing more he can
do to speed up the process in September
of 1938 after another fun summer in
Poland we prepare again to return to
school Fred's new school and Fred is
Max's brother I fail to mention it's all
in the book Fred's new school is called
Adolf Hitler junior high school and he
talks about how because they were
because they were polish they were able
to go to the school right even though
they were Jewish this is this is a
little bit of a longer section but you
know I've written a bunch of kids books
and you know the kids books are written
from the perspective of a 10 year old
kid and then he turns 11 and then he
turns 12 but the mind you know when I
wrote them of course I've kind of got
myself into the mindset of a 10 year old
kid and what their thoughts are and when
I'm reading this section from the
perspective of a 10 year old kid or a
nine year old kid which max was at the
time it really it it's it's very hard to
get through to understand what it was
like for kids so this is from max yeah
on October 28th 1938 I am nine years old
and settling into fourth grade math
class where we are working on the eight
times tables although it is not common
on this day I make an error in
multiplying my teacher approaches me and
slaps me across the face I am shocked
it's not the pain from the slap that
upsets me I am upset because no one has
ever treated me like this at school
before and I don't know how to respond
for the moment I choose to be quiet
so as to not draw attention to myself
again I will have to think about what is
happening here before I choose to act my
cheek burns from the slap and from shame
later that day two German SI officers
known as
troopers or brown shirts come to the
class and call out my name I stand at my
desk to acknowledge that they called me
wondering why did they somehow know
about the math error for which I'd been
slapped my heart is pumping even harder
than it was after the slap the officers
approach me take me under their arms and
begin walking I have no idea idea where
we are going or why but I have no choice
but to go with them I don't understand
what is happening that German SA
officers don't explain anything and I
decide not to ask despite being very
frightened and wanting to know where
they're taking me they marched me out of
the school and through the town never
pausing or explaining to me what is
happening along the way we pass our
synagogue where people ask where are you
going I respond that I don't know
we march straight to the local jail and
they shove me behind bars without
explanation the jail is loud confusing
and frightening there are many other
Polish Jews with me in jail I can tell
by their clothes that all of them were
taken from their task at hand and
brought directly there
there are women still wearing aprons
from their cooking in their kitchens men
are wearing suits from their work
children have their school bags from the
classroom no one understands what is
happening many keep asking for
explanations and some are crying Jews of
all ages and professions have been
rounded up and brought to this jail
so and he goes into this he thinks that
the reason that all this is happening in
his mind is cuz he got a math problem
wrong and he continues to think that for
a little while
fast forward a little bit
the officers command everyone to listen
up all Polish Jews are being sent back
to Poland dad says they call it the
repatriation of Jews to Poland but he
says the truth is Polish Jews are now
exiled from Germany shortly thereafter
everyone in jails told the march in a
group and then here they go getting on
board of a train as I climb onto the
train I realize it is packed with Polish
Jews there is no extra room at all the
doors are then locked dad says the train
is moving toward Poland dad has to hand
over almost all our money as well
no one resists this injustice but our
parents faces show me how much of a
problem this is for our family fast
forward it takes some time but we can
feel and hear the movement of the engine
on the tracks as it leaves behind us as
it leaves us behind the guards unlock
our train car and allow everyone to
leave mom and dad tell us that they saw
a sign as we pulled into the station and
we are now in Sebastian Poland so
they've been relocated and at one point
and he tells a harrowing story in here
where his mom and dad leave then they
say hey you just stay here on the train
and they leave to try and figure out
what they're gonna do when they leave
another the train starts to move yes and
Max and his brothers don't know what to
do but they figure you know their mom
and dad had said stay here you know stay
wait for us we'll be back so they decide
they're gonna jump out of the Train
so they throw their luggage in their
bags and they jump out of the Train and
it turns out that the train was just
being kind of relocated on the tracks a
little bit just going back and forth a
little bit but the the just horror that
forces them to make this split-second
decision and again you're talking about
kids talk about little kids
so now they're in Poland in the middle
of night November 1930 and our parents
decide to continue on to Brett's Co
Jessica Jessica Jessica Jessica Poland
to Grandpa Schindler's house after two
weeks our parents tell us we are leaving
and again I'm I'm just reading some of
the highlights to capture the story yeah
you've got the detail that he puts in
here is is really powerful after two
weeks our tell our parents tell us we
are leaving this time we are going to
get grandma shreads
she is rides home her big farm house has
enough space for all of us also because
the farm is in a small village out of
the country there seems to be less risk
of Germans soldiers finding us mom and
dad let us know that this is where we
plan to stay grandma's farm is
self-sustaining with horses cows ducks
chickens fields with crops and a big
garden I'm not accustomed to this much
farming caring for animals using an
outhouse and keeping light and lighting
kerosene lamps instead of turning on a
switch Fred feels the same but we both
know not to complain this is our new
life and we need to adjust because there
are no other options we get lessons in
all farm life topics because we must
work the farm to help our family dad
cannot sell liquor like he did before he
is now a farmer while we are working in
the fields hoeing picking and planning
dad teaches about teaches us about
farming and our Jewish faith the Polish
kids are not kind to us or any of the
Jewish children the Jewish students
stick together to avoid the Polish kids
as much as possible and fast-forwarding
here as the war approaches the hostility
and aggression towards Jews
gets noticeably worse my polish
classmates harassed me and want to fight
with me I get involved in some serious
fights with these kids our fights often
include throwing rocks into homes the
situation has become truly dangerous I
am fortunate to have my brother and
cousins close by when kids attempt to
fight with me I can always find support
and family members
so fast-forward a little bit now the war
kicks off within a day or two the
beginning of the war the polls aligned
with the Germans they put on German
uniforms and want to be part of the
German war effort they call themselves
the Polish Fox Deutsch and circulate
rumors that the whole city of is going
to be gassed the local people are very
frightened and go indoors sealing their
windows and tape with tape to keep the
gas out all the villagers including us
stay inside for two or three days as a
result the streets are barren of people
this is how the Germans march in and
take over the city without firing a
single shot the Germans now occupy all
of Poland and have taken over there is a
real possibility of being captured
during the German SS roundups
the Jews that are caught are sent into a
ghetto or a concentration camp
my parents are frantic about this
possibility and will do nearly anything
to avoid it they have heard about the
horrors of life in the ghettos and the
concentration camps our parents are now
frightened and trying to find a safe
place for us I know I am terrified there
doesn't seem to be any good choices left
so many things keep changing while we
were in occupied Poland the German
officers nail orders to trees and
signposts to communicate their latest
edicts this is how we learned that
Jewish kids can no longer attend school
another edict is posted in 1941 ordering
all Jews to wear a Jewish star on their
clothes over their heart mom sews the
stars on our clothes for us while
explaining that we must follow the
orders in order to avoid being punished
we know that we may have lost their
lives by resisting we know that many
have lost their lives by resisting the
Germans are dangerous and unpredictable
so we do what we are told many times the
Germans marched down the Main Street
near Grandma's house when this happens
news of the German soldiers coming
travels quickly to the families this
this time we hear about them from the
neighbors and move hurry and quietly
into the forest to hide mom grabs food
and water because we may have to stay
all day long or even overnight until the
Germans leave the area while we are
hiding in the woods
grandma stays in her store and acts
relaxed and normal serving the German
soldiers to make us to keep us safe she
tells them she is
old widow just trying to make a living
the soldiers must believe her because
they do not search for us mom and dad
talk about how brave she is grandma's
risking her life because if the soldiers
found out she was hiding Jews on her
farm we would all certainly be shot yeah
this is a matter of years you had to
have so much hope in situations like
this hoping that it's going to get
better
okay things will change that's a lot of
us survived it's it's shocking to me how
quickly all this happens and how you go
these I mean even in your small village
you go okay well there's 2,000 people in
that village it takes a and and it gets
through that village pretty quickly you
can understand that but now we're
talking about all of Germany all of
Poland this is before the internet this
is before cellphones
this is word-of-mouth and people nailing
edicts to trees and this transition from
this idyllic situation for for both your
families and for the Jews in these
situations to to this horror in a matter
of a couple of years right unbelievable
well this was going on nobody nobody
said a word the whole world was quiet
where was the world when this was going
on on a personal level what was it like
with you know a little Christian girl a
little girl that you knew that you
played with and then one day she doesn't
play with you right she they started
calling us dirty Jew throwing rocks at
us they didn't want to have anything to
do with us
and before that most of the people made
a living from the Jews yeah all worked
for us because they're all in business
the Jewish people
so now we just have to hope that things
will get better the the the non
resisting in both your parents and Max's
parents both are look we gotta just do
what we're told right we have no choice
and the reason is because the that you
otherwise it's almost like an immediate
execution right this is it's so hard to
believe what we went through it's really
hard for anybody to believe what we gone
through but it's so horrible hard for
what what happened
going back to you one of your parts in
the book in 1941 I'm nearly eleven years
old and there's another new rule we must
wear a gold star of david' on our sleeve
so everyone will know we are Jewish I
don't understand why only Jewish people
have to wear an identifying patch and
follow special rules a few months later
another change comes into our family on
Sunday the men and boys are that are old
enough are rounded up by soldiers and
loaded onto trucks that includes Tata
and fishel they are driven out of town
and as I watch the truck pull out of
sight I wonder where they are taking
them a few days later when the men
haven't returned I hear women in the
village questioning aloud to one another
if the men are ever coming back
thoughts I will find a way to come home
to us I know when the men finally
arrived home on a Friday night Tata
official look exhausted as they descent
from the truck tantas face has deep
grooves in it that are dark brown with
dirt officials clothes which used to be
blue and gray now on muddy brown flakes
of cake caked on mud shed off as close
as he makes his way over to us when they
approach they say nothing only nodded us
tiredly tata smiles at me when i wave
and takes my hand in his as we walked
toward the house later that night after
tata unofficial watch up wash up we are
all sitting around the Shabbat dinner
table Tata tells mamma that they are
being forced to work for the Germans it
is hard labor labor and the men feel
like slaves as they are never
for their work they are given very
little food and very little water when
mama asks what they are doing for the
Germans Tata says they pave roads cut
wood for bridges lay foundations dig
ditches and sometimes they work in
factories no matter what they are doing
they work hard long hours the guards
watch them closely throughout the day
and threaten anyone who hasn't working
hard enough
Tata says he and fishel keep their heads
down and work steadily so they can come
home to us on Friday nights yeah you
can't even explain how horrible this was
unbelievable one night when Tata and
fishel are sitting quietly by the stove
I asked Tata why no one does anything
about this situation doctor sighs and
says Rosie we have to be patient follow
the rules since we are not in charge of
course we would like to be paid but we
can't force them to pay us God will
reward us for being kind to the
Hungarians people whisper all around me
that Jews are to turn in their radios we
are no longer allowed access to public
information or news program I hear
whispers among the adults about what
could be happening in other places many
people look grim and shake their heads
as they head home to inform their
families
I run nearly all the way home to tell
mama I learned later that only one
Jewish family keeps a radio in the
cellar of their home defying their rule
this is a huge risk because if the
Hungarians find out they will kill all
the people in that house right now I'm
gonna fast forward you guys live under
these conditions I mean just brutal
conditions and then we get in the spring
of 1944 I'm nearly 14 years old and
living under the fascist rule of the
Hungarians my village is different
lockdown and under their rule Jews are
prisoners in our village forced to stay
put and avoid being seen or noticed
non-jews run the town having taken over
all the shops mama looks tired and Tata
has gone most of the time I miss him so
much especially because he always helped
me understand
world right now the world doesn't make
any sense to me I missed my old life
even school one morning a month before
Passover as I am playing with my sisters
in the lane I hear loud noises coming
from down the road as we watch soldiers
in dark green uniforms and black helmets
March into town they wear tall black
boots thick leather belt to a shiny
buckles and a large red armband with a
spider on it I'm unsure who these
soldiers are I've never seen uniforms
like these before
I am worried this this time I do not
wave to the soldiers they make me feel
worried Germans
I hear several women whisper I studied
the outfits of the German soldiers and
wonder how these women know them to be
German how have they come to take over
our country
those are SS one announces what's the SS
another asks the Secret Service
I heard they are the most brutal of the
German Nazi forces
it's interesting that even you as a
young girl when you saw the Hungarian
soldiers you know you were a little
concerned but when you see the Nazis
your instinct is lately different
absolutely because my mother and father
actually were born in Hungary so we
didn't think it was so awful because
they were born in Hungary and nothing
would happen but of course everything
did we never expect never thought
anything so Honda was ahead of us what
happened to us you go on here one day as
we are all chopping vegetables in the
chicken in the kitchen
mama interrupts the conversation with a
very serious look on her face girls I
know that things are confusing you need
to continue to act as if nothing is
wrong acting strangely can get us into
trouble if you mind your own business
and act natural the soldiers will ignore
you and leave you alone that's the hope
yeah
fast forward a little bit here when the
seven days of Passover are over mama
sends me to the bakery to buy bread
during Passover we eat no bread I cannot
wait to taste bread again and I hurry
into town to buy it on my way out of the
bakery with my fresh loaves tucked under
my arm
I hear the town crier beating his drum I
joined the other people and gather
around him to listen to the news he
tells everyone that all Jews are being
shipped out by train they need to pack a
bag of belongings and go to the school
within 48 hours I rushed home to tell
mama but she has already heard the news
I'm relieved
tops unofficial our home and not at work
camp so we can all be together mama and
Tata also know we need to bring
valuables to the school for registration
and safekeeping Tata decides not to
follow this rule and wants to hide our
valuable jewelry instead so he actually
takes some of the jewelry
hides it a little shoe polish box and
then puts it up up above a beam between
the ceiling and the wall and the corner
and your sisters didn't even want to
know where it was gonna be you're the
only one that was brave enough to say
okay dad tell me
my father said come with me I want to
show it to you so when you come back
after the wall you know where it is so
my two sisters my Helen enjoyed it they
don't want any part of it so I told my
father I'll go with you
so we went to the corner of one of the
rooms in the house took a ladder and my
father opened a little area between the
ceiling and the wall in the corner and
we put there wasn't much jewelry because
we didn't you have my jewelry in those
days my father had an wedding band and I
Anna and his pocket watch by the way
this is a chain from my my father's
pocket watch I wear that every day
that's the chain he put into that box
this is one of the chains and my mother
all she had was a pair of earrings a
necklace and a wedding band there maybe
a little something else so a little shoe
polish box was plenty big for that so we
hit it and we had we covered it with
dirt so nobody should notice it so after
we came back after the war I knew
exactly where it was and so we divided
the jewelry between the three of us so
now the day comes when the day when the
next day arrives mama instructs us to
wear three layers of our best clothes
because we don't know where we are going
or how long we'll be gone no one knows
when we will be able to do laundry I
choose my warmest clothes and Mama packs
are down quilts in case it gets cold we
each pack a burlap bag with our
belongings I'm excited to travel on a
train for the first time as I have never
gone beyond the neighboring towns on
either side of my village when the time
comes to leave we are all packed and
ready it's april 1944 and how you sarah
who is now 21 and yuki who is 19 helped
mama and aunt Lee with the younger kids
fishless 16 and I am 14 years old Paige
thirteen blim chu is 10 Faye is maybe
our fire bear is 6 years old
Tata and Mama lead her whole family
toward the school with each of the older
kids carrying a burlap bag of belongings
there are a lot of people at the school
when we arrive and all of them are
Jewish this train station is the biggest
building I've ever been in I hear some
of the adults talking about how the
station transports shipments of bricks
all over Europe from the brick factory
here mama points out that Jews from all
the neighboring villages are here in
Anwar with us we remain in the train
station for 3 or 4 weeks under the
watchful eyes of Hungarian soldiers with
guard dogs we sleep in tents at night
the soldiers remind us regularly that
Jews are not to try and run away or they
will be shot our parents continue to
reassure us that we should not worry as
God will protect us and then the story
here is the story that I read in the
opening of you actually getting on the
train you're packed in there you're
traveling for days and finally when the
when the when you arrive the door is
unlocked and a man in a blue and white
uniform climbs into our cattle car and
tells us we know hash words our store
it's Poland he begins telling people
what to do next and helping them move
their belongings he asked me how old I
am and I tell him I'm 14 years old he
murmurs tell them you're 18 you key is
telling is holding my little brother
Meyer bare the man asks her if this is
her child no he's my brother she replies
he tells her that young children must
stay with their mothers he gives
information to many people as we climb
down off the cattle car once we once on
the ground all luggage and possessions
are tossed into a big pile we are put
into rows of five people and directed to
walk on for about five minutes there's
no talking allowed and everyone is
confused because we don't know what's
coming next when we arrive in front of
three German SS
officers in uniform they begin to
separate us into groups one of them
asked me how old I am
and I follow the advice of the man on
the train I tell the soldier that I'm 18
years old hi Astoria responds no she
isn't she's 14
no I'm 18 I insist the officers waved my
sisters and me to the left Totten
official are directed to the line in the
right while mama aunt Lee and my three
little sisters and baby brother go
forward joining another line of people I
don't know why they are separating us
but you keep telling me to be quiet and
not ask questions just do what they say
she insists the guards quickly move
everyone along so there is no time to
talk to mama or Tata I try to keep my
eyes on them as their lines move and off
in different directions
but I quickly lose sight of them I
wonder how long it will be until I see
them again
maybe they separate men from women here
but that doesn't explain why mama aunt
Lee and the little kids went in another
line so many things are happening that
don't make sense to me my thoughts get
interrupted when the soldiers yell at us
to keep moving Yuki hiya Sora and I
follow our line into a big bathroom
marked lager camp see maybe here we will
wash up after being stuck in the cattle
car for days instead we are ordered to
take off all our clothes and toss them
in a pile I slowly remove the three
dresses that mama had me wear I pause
when I have stripped down to my
underwear and look at the many women
around me everyone is undressing I have
never been naked in front of strangers
before and I am feeling confused and
humiliated this is so wrong but no one
is saying anything when hiya Sora and
Yuki start removing their undergarments
like the other women I slowly do too I
am shivering and feel scared the
soldiers take photograph of photographs
as US of us humiliating us further I
think this must be held because I have
never experienced anything worse I am
appalled to realize that the next step
is to have every hair shaved off our
bodies I cannot understand why they need
to take hair off my head arms legs and
even my most private places I can see
other Jewish women don't understand
what is going on either and look ashamed
the faces of all the women shaving us
are like stone showing no emotion at all
I feel so exposed with no clothes and
now no hair to cover me I reach up to
touch my hairless head and I'm shocked
to feel my nubby and bruised scalp from
the rough handling of the emotionless
women with the razor after we are shaved
we are ordered to grab a dress from a
pile on the cement floor and given
wooden clogs the clog seemed to be all
the same size but don't really fit
anymore they are hard and difficult to
walk in I have to shuffle the get any
wear my hair straight my dress hangs
down to the ground like a sack since my
head is freezing I tear off a piece of
fabric from the bottom of my dress to
wrap around my head at least my head is
covered but I am still very cold I don't
understand why I can't retrieve my old
socks and undergarments that are in a
heap on the floor close by as soon as we
are dressed we are forced to go outside
and line up for zell Appel say a lot
poems a lapel which is a roll call right
it is now late in the evening and there
are so many people moving about that I
get separated for my sister's I'm
frightened and frantically call out
their names two bald women and dingy
dresses approached me they reach for me
and reassure me Rosie it's us I hug them
both fiercely and stammer I did not
recognize you I'm so relieved to be with
them that I can't stop shaking
so I mean any illusion that things were
gonna work out in any way that could be
remotely considered humane musts are
completely shattered at this point
completely shattered I mean you know
when you're being told hey pack a bag
hey get on the train like those things
don't sound good but they at least sound
they at least sounded somewhat
reasonable they sound like a reasonable
okay we got our bag we're going to be
taken somewhere all that is completely
gone now absolutely absolutely and
you're 14 years old right how tall are
you 5 1 so you're this little girl just
followed rules whatever they are saying
we have to just follow them things
happened so fast
you cannot imagine we didn't even have
time to think about anything go here go
there do this do that and that's it you
know it's it's one of the things that
they do in the military right is they
take you they take everything that you
have they shave your head and they're
they're trying to get rid of your
individuality right they want to they
want to remove some of that and this is
just the exact you know what they're did
there but they're doing it to a to an
absolute extreme you know stripping you
naked and shaving your entire body and
just removing anything that you had from
the past I don't think you can compare
that to the military no I'm not I'm not
trying to compare it to the military I'm
I guess I'm just trying to say that the
idea I guess well the idea of when they
shave your head in the military part of
what they're doing is trying to take
away from some of your individuality
right so that you can become part of the
group here they're trying to take away
your humanity
that's it that's what they did
going on here it says all of us notice a
huge fire spewing heavy smoke that looks
like a burning Mountain across the open
area from us
I can see shadows of people moving
through the smoke and can hear the cries
of children there is an overpowering
foul smell coming from the fire somehow
I taste the fire in my mouth
Yuki asked the guard as she gestures
toward the fire what is all that noise
about the guard responds they're burning
hair
Yuki replies burning hair would not make
such a noise to which he snaps they are
burning cripples a sick feeling comes
over me as I realized the guards and
soldiers are barbaric cold-blooded
animals so that's your first recognition
that we are going to receive zero right
humanity from these guards absolutely
you can't even explain how things were
they were so horrible so unbelievable
and this all went on for so long nobody
tried to help us because this is 1944
right so this had been going on this was
five months before our part of the world
was liberated you know that by September
1944 our part was liberated by the
Russians
going back to the book berrak 26 is our
sleeping quarters I've never seen
anything like it before
dirt floors and rows of wooden
three-tiered bunks no straw filled
mattresses no blankets or pillows no
heat a fireplace that doesn't work hi
you Sarah Yuki and I are assigned to the
top bunk with five other women we climb
up in huddle body to body to stay warm
during the freezing cold night I am so
thankful that my sisters are with me
because everything is foreign harsh
unexplained and unbearably cold the next
morning I decide to look around the camp
to figure out where we are
I assure my sisters there are a lot of
people milling around and I can blend in
or hide I will be careful I walk outside
I'm shocked to see many barracks just
like the one we slept in arranged in
rows of buildings there are dozens of
people walking around outdoors all
shaved all shivering some are wandering
around like zombies when I try to talk
to one of these zombie like women she
just stares through me doesn't answer
and keeps walking she is truly
frightening to me it is as though she is
here but not really here at all there is
a 12-foot electric fence encircling the
camp
dead people hang from the fence their
bodies contorted I wonder why so many
would grab onto the electric fence to
end their life what kind of hell are we
in why are we prisoners feeling like a
second-class citizen at home was nothing
compared to this I'm on a mission to
learn all I can so I ask those who have
been here longer to help me understand
most of the women are very patient with
me asking questions because they
remember how frightening in foreign
everything was for them when they
arrived they explained that some people
cannot endure the severity of the camp
and know that if they hold onto the
electric electrified fence their life
ends in 20 seconds one thing I learned
for certain is no one can escape there
are guards with guns the deadly electric
fence and people watching your every
move this must be hell
unbelievable unexplainable the half-dead
zombie like people in the bodies
clinging to the electric fence or
overpowering I am in a daze seeing the
true horrors of war here as I walk
around I think I hear my Yiddish name
called out softly how could anyone in
this godforsaken place know my Yiddish
name but then I hear it again
Rosie I turned to see a man in a striped
uniform who I did not recognize but who
is beckoning to me he approaches me and
says don't you know who I am
I'm your Tata with a wave of pure shock
I realized it is Tata I'm tremendously
relieved at home thoughts always wore a
suit and a hat and glasses and had a
beard I look again at this man with no
hair and I know it's him I hug him as
tight as I can cry and kiss him and kiss
him some more his arms around me are the
first sense of warmth I've felt since
arriving
top-2 explains that he and fishel were
selected to go work in a factory they
will leave soon but in the meantime he
has been looking everywhere for his
family he decided we must be in the this
all-women's camp where the Hungarian
people are sent where is your mother he
asks I don't know but I have you keen
how you solder with me whatever you do
stay together because you will have a
much better chance of survival
Tata replies I think what chance does a
fourteen-year-old have of surviving in a
place like this but I don't say anything
Tata holds both of my arms at my side it
looks me in the eyes and sternly says
make sure you stay alive so you can tell
the world what they are doing to us I
sure am I will do my best then he and I
make plans for us to meet again tomorrow
at this spot
that's a heavy charge from yeah
unbelievable you know every time I open
the book and I go through it a little
bit i I just can't believe that this
happened to us that the world allowed
this and the world knew what was going
on but nobody tried to help us just
because you're very Jewish
I'm gonna continue on the next day
yu-gi-oh Sora and I wait at the
designated spot to meet up with Tata and
Vishal when we see them I cry in relief
we all hug and kiss each other and we
are so happy to have time together tata
repeats his solemn advice to each of us
do your best to stay together stay alive
so you can tell the world what they are
doing to us the next day we go to our
spot to meet Tata official as planned we
wait and wait and wait for what seems to
like an eternity but they do not come
fast forward a little bit how you Sora
Yuki and I have no choice but to stay
together in this evil place we share a
bunk bed meals and one bathroom with a
thousand women no one is allowed to use
the bathroom at night it has sinks with
cold running water but no soap for us to
wash up there's no toilet just a hole in
the ground there is nowhere to shower or
take baths we only have one plain dress
we were are wearing and no way to clean
it except with the cold water without a
shower or soap we are constantly filthy
we are always itching with the bites of
lice and bedbugs we can rinse out our
dress and walk around naked while it
dries it doesn't really matter because
we are surrounded by 28,000 women in the
same predicament we have no way really
to clean our dress or our clogs we are
left to rot for months in the same
horrible dress I realize quickly this
concentration camp has some predictable
events every day as they count us every
day they count us as we stand in rows of
five people at 5 a.m. the guard shouts
get up get up
Chanel schnell quick quick we all rise
and run outdoors to be counted whether
it is freezing rainy or sunny we stand
in lines for hours three times a day
until the guards have a tally then we
are released back to our barracks I'm
told this is how they know how much
space is available for the new people
they bring in by train every day people
leave to go to work in factories get
killed or are gassed so the counting is
necessary sometimes we are forced to
kneel and hold up rocks until our arms
if you
like they will break in the rocks fall
other times they make us move rocks from
one spot to another then back to the
original location it doesn't make any
sense but we don't ask questions we keep
our heads down and do what we are told
because any resistance may mean we will
be shot I've seen it happen
I cannot escape the horrible smell of
the crematoriums chimney of the burning
bodies 24 hours a day the sickening
stench of burning flesh makes me want to
vomit and never becomes less upsetting
emotionally the smoke and smell burn a
black hole in my heart we have to find a
way out of this place and that will
require me knowing as much as possible
about how it is run women explained that
prisoners are chosen for jobs and they
must comply any Jewish worker who
resists is shot dead on the spot
strong Jewish women called Capo's are
put in charge of running each barrack
the Capitals live amongst us in the
barrack and watch everything they are
not paid but they have certain rights
that others lack they may get more food
but they are doing the dirty work for
the Germans the cooks preparing the
meals are Jewish as well
Jews clean out the bathroom in the
barracks that is used by 28 thousand
women Jews even worked the gas chamber
everything was done by the Jews if you
didn't do it they would shoot you on the
spot you had no choice they would see
their own families go into the gas
chamber
and there was not anything they could do
or say
you say here this is too much for me to
process and I begin to see why some
people touch the electric fence to end
their misery
I asked repeatedly why we can hear
people crying out near the crematorium I
learned that when a group is gassed in
the showers not all the people are dead
when they burn the bodies maybe they
don't give them enough gas because we
can hear the screaming coming from the
crematorium the men running the
incinerators called Sonderkommando s'
will be sent in to them soon so they
cannot tell the world what is happening
so you even have the the Jews are
running the factories they're joining
the gas chambers they're running
everything and eventually they're going
in them too absolutely yes
usually the gas chambers I've heard from
many people say that after three months
they would change the guards at the gas
chambers livid every three months a bur
changing the ones that were there three
months they put him in the gas chamber
and they get new ones in so the end of
three months you're going to the gas
chamber yes the people working there yes
at the gas chambers would you talk to
other people would you talk to other
people besides your sisters was there
any sense of community no was it just
broken spirit a broken spirit and the
thing is Pete came to Auschwitz and they
were always people he couldn't make you
couldn't become friends with any of the
people here because we were all only
there we were in camp see ok and how
she's working out and this was a
transitional camp you come you get
selected and you lead the only people
that stayed behind this ones like me
because I was skin and bone and it
wouldn't select me to go to work I would
run out of the gas chamber line and hope
nobody sees me they would see me they
would shoot me on the spot they did not
want to take people to factories the
word that were scanner
Bowen okay so so it's just you and your
sisters everyone else is kind of
transient yes and your and there's no
feeling of community no none whatsoever
it's just broken spirits absolutely you
never know who's gonna be there tomorrow
we had 28 we had 30 barracks in this
place okay well one barrack was a
kitchen one bear it was a bathroom and
people were coming in all the time
coming and going coming and going and of
course there were so many dead bodies
always and in our camp they would come
they would commit suicide by touching
the electric fences they just good luck
couldn't take it anymore you touch the
fence 20 seconds later you see blood
coming out of the nose and you're dead
and they would pick up they would come
with those big wheelbarrows every day to
collect the dead bodies
you say here one day I asked a woman who
I haven't seen my mother on my little
sisters and brother the lady is careful
to gently tell me what I think I already
know she sadly affirms that my worst
fears are correct when they got off the
train they were put in a line that led
directly to the gas chamber I would say
80% of the people that came in on the
trains went into the gas chamber all the
mothers children the sick the crippled
the old age the only people they try to
say were the ones that could go for
slave labor
go to factories to work you continue on
here they remind me of how lucky I was
to be accepted as being 18 and eligible
for the adult factory work line if thus
orders had known I was 14 I would have
gone with my mother and aunt and younger
siblings straight to the gas chamber I
do not feel lucky in any way right now I
just can't get used to the idea that my
mother three sisters and little brother
are gone it is beyond beyond
comprehension when you ki house ara and
I try to talk about it we cannot speak
we just cry yeah we have to keep going
like Tata told us it will eventually get
better we believe we need to have hope
right I have difficulty processing all
of this and have to keep asking myself
why why why and I think this this
section right here is one of the most
powerful pieces you say this one of the
ladies hugs me close and says you will
never understand what these Germans are
doing because it is beyond comprehension
it does not make sense and it never will
they are crazy
out of their minds you are not remember
you are the sane one here go where you
need to go
inside of yourself and remember who you
are they cannot steal your soul unless
you give it to them never give them your
soul follow the rules and survive so
that the real you can blossom again when
you are free war is a horrible thing but
it will end when it does there is
another life for you outside of
Auschwitz and you need to live for that
that's how I survived really by hoping
and think things no no no that things
would be better someday and I guess I
mean the difference between having that
attitude of things will get better
someday and thinking that they won't
those are the people that are gonna go
and grab the electric fence that's it
they just gave up they couldn't handle
it anymore who was this woman do you
remember who this woman was that told
you this I have no idea
probably some somebody much older than
me remember I was a 14 year old I was a
young kid did you did you believe I mean
it had to be hard looking at these
surroundings to believe that this could
be that there really could be hope
beyond this well if I did not have hope
I listened to my father he said whatever
you do stay alive so you can tell the
world what they're doing to us okay that
was your mission that was my mission
actually it was more my mission they my
to sit all the sisters they would get
very angry with me sometime because I
would do things that was not the right
thing to do in a place like this okay
well you take risks right absolutely
you're a little bit of a hard person to
subdue actually even as a child many
times the mother said you're acting like
a boy you're not acting like a young
lady
here's another little part about what
you guys are eating the only thing we
got for breakfast is black coffee new to
describe what the black coffees the
black off he's not coffee at all it's
horrible it was horrible
I took one sip and that that's the only
time I ever tried it
I thought I was gonna throw up so hard
but you say we are literally starving
we are absolutely lunch is nothing but a
piece of bread slice of thin slice of
bread was a piece of larger yes
occasionally will give us butter to put
on it the bread is dry and hard and
there we are told they put sawdust in it
we line up outdoors to get a bread to
get our bread at a table staffed by the
kitchen and women we do not share our
bread it is coveted and sometimes hidden
away for later the food tastes horrible
and is not enough to live on it is not
surprising that some prisoners here have
a German nickname muscleman that right
yeah which means skeletal or skin and
bones so many people are too thin and I
am becoming one of them at dinner time
we get a pot of soup to share among a
dozen women we are hungry every day
there's never enough to eat an officer
comes in the barracks and shouts I need
300 women for selection for factory work
many women hurry outside to be selected
anything must be better than this place
once they line up everyone removes their
clothes the officers can examine their
physique to decide if they are healthy
and strong enough to do factory or work
if a woman is too weak or thin they
label her as a muscleman and send her to
the gas chamber I don't know if it is
because of food or illness but I have a
bad bout of diarrhea and I'm very weak I
can't stand and walk for the first few
weeks of my illness utsuki and higher
sada will not go outside to be selected
without me so we hide when the officers
call for volunteers it's not hard to
hide with a thousand people in the
barracks and they only need 200 or 300
women the officers do not notice me this
works for the first three or four weeks
but I am just skin and bones now I know
I need to be selected for a factory to
get out of here yukine hire saara
help me stand up and pinch my cheeks so
I look like I have some color the
comes when I undress I'm so frightened
because I know I'm too thin and weak to
be chosen my worst fears come true when
the officers call me muscleman and send
me to the gas chamber line it is a
torturous few minutes walk into that
line my sisters help me get there
holding me under my arms as we cry and
panic there's so much going on around us
that I begin to wonder if we can somehow
sneak away I tell you keen hi Sarah what
I am thinking and we agreed to try it we
have no other choice at the agreed-upon
moment we calmly step out of the line
and head straight back to our barrack
all of our hearts are pumping wildly if
an SS officer notices will be shot on
the spot luckily there are a lot of
women moving about the camp and no one
notices you have any idea what you wait
at this point I have no idea but you're
just skin and bones I was very I was
even at home I was very thin okay I was
not a big eater this wasn't good that
wasn't good you know when you're a child
[Music]
and and the gas chamber line that's you
know exactly what that is absolutely you
know when I get in this line I'm gonna
be dead in three minutes or whatever the
nine minutes is and they they're just
walking down the line they look at you
two skinny muscleman go over there one
over here one over there right so they
always put me in the gas chamber line
okay and I would make sure nobody sees
me I would get out of the gas chamber
line if they would catch me they would
probably shoot me on the spot remember
we had we had close to over 28,000
people women in that camp okay and and
you know they brought in over 500,000
Hungarian Jews to Auschwitz April and
May of 1944 and everybody that came into
our streets
he went into camp see
or the gas chambers you had to have a
lot of guts to survive and also hope
hope for a better day okay and you you
are a risk-taker yes
I mean clearly you're taking a risk by
going out there getting in line you're
taking a risk by getting out of line
yeah you got a lot of bravery in these
situations you had to if you didn't
you're gone the only people that survive
are the ones that are bravest really you
say food is such a problem for all of us
but particularly for me since I am too
thin at lunch one day we stand in line
outside to get our bread as usual the
capo gives me a slice of bread which I
noticed is half its usual size I am
hungry so I speak without thinking my
bread is cut in half I cruised accuse
her the capo is furious with me because
my accusation can get hurt a lot of
trouble with the Germans she pulls me
out of line and takes me to where the
German SS officers will be sure to see
her actions she beats me so brutally
that I cannot stand for three days
afterwards my sisters are both concerned
and frustrated with me for getting into
trouble
Yuki tells me next time just shut up
don't ever complain about anything again
it'll only get you in trouble do you
want to get shot I know she's right but
I struggled at the injustice we are
already starving how can they steal half
my meager food still I need to learn to
keep my mouth shut
well what was the what how did you guys
look at the kapos I don't know if we
even looked at them all we knew is Avery
there okay we didn't see them too often
the only time we saw them is when they
came to select people to go to factories
to work did you look at them as fellow
Jews David oh you mean a cop Oh tapas oh
excuse me I thought you were talking
about the SS well they had to do the
work otherwise they would get shot if
they don't do what they were asked to do
and they would not do the job but when
the cop was when they did get these jobs
they could get extra food they could
get extra all kinds of things you know
what I mean they were in charge of a
thousand women in every batter so they
had to be very strong and do the right
thing otherwise they wouldn't do it
they wouldn't choose him to do it what
was the V was your view of the Capo's
like hey they're just doing what they
have to do to survive I don't know if he
did when we were there but now I know
that they had to do what they chosen to
do they had no choice okay but they were
our own people that did this work you go
in here today good fortune is upon us
one of the ladies in barrack 26 tells us
that we have a cousins in barrack 3 we
are shocked and all three of us begin
asking questions in rapid succession
what are the names how did you find them
are you sure
how do you figure out we're related and
barrack 3 my cousins are in charge of
the whole barrack including food
distribution they help give me extra
food every day and I begin to gain
weight and think more clearly
it literally saves my life to have a
little more food I'm so thankful to be
with them in this horrible place yeah
so there's another little thing that
allows you to survive right right it was
amazing that they found out I mean so
many thousands of women over there and
they were all the way in the beginning
of the camp number 2 or 3 I'm not really
sure ok and they were in charge of
giving out the food so of course when we
got there we would get extra whatever
there was
as the months go slowly by in September
of 1944 we noticed that Ash wits begins
to empty out our cousins are taken to
work in a factory and so we are sad to
see them go as the barracks residence
dwindle
it makes our exit more urgent now there
are less people hiding nest less people
to hide among we at risk of being
noticed I am getting stronger and less
skeletal so I urge my sister's just to
try selection with me again but I am
labeled as a muscleman and sent to the
gas chamber like skin and bones mousse
oh man at least I can get out of line
now on my own and head back to the
barrack I do this repeatedly enough that
we decide I can no longer go through the
selection process at all sooner or later
though I will be caught sneaking away
from the line and shot there has to be
another way we have to get out of here
repeats over and over in my mind I know
we cannot give up because I have hope I
always remember what my father told me
stay together because your chances of
survival will be much better it is not
easy to keep hope alive and we are in
camp giving up seems easier and we see
many who do give up and end up on the
electric fencing there are a few good
rumors that help us have hope women
gather in the bathroom to hear the
latest rumor that the Americans or
Russians may liberate us the hope that
we will reunite with Tata and fishel
keeps us alive even with this hope it is
hard to continue believing in something
we all question our faith in God how
could God allow this to happen
following the Jewish laws got us nowhere
one day in 1944 the SS officers arrived
at the barracks and announcing they need
300 women to go to a German factory in
Freud and how frightened thyroid in
doubt this is the day that Yuki house
ara and I will be chosen I know it as we
are getting up to the line as we were
preparing to line up I look at my
sisters and tell them go get selected
and save me a place in line I will fail
find a way to sneak into the group how
you saw her and Yuki both look worried
but go out and front the front door and
get selected I must find a way to get in
line
being detected meanwhile I am working
feverishly to come up with a plan to
join them our barracks are always
guarded by capitals no matter what my
heart races so loudly that I wonder that
if others can hear it as I try to figure
out what to do I don't have much time I
must think fast i watch a woman who
gives out food from our kitchen as she
exits the back of the barrack suddenly I
find myself running as fast as I can
down the long hallway of the barrack
toward the back door the female capo
guarding the door raises her hand to
stop me my heart is beating hard in my
chest as she looks at me you can't go
out this door you have to go out that
way to be selected for work she says
pointing in the opposite direction I
don't want to go to work I say shaking
my head my mother has just gone out that
door and I need to go with her as I
point to the door behind her the seconds
pass the seconds that passed before she
responds feel like hours I continue to
reach toward the door employing her to
let help me somehow the capo takes pity
on me and lets me out the door i scan
the area for guards as I sneak around
the building to join my sisters in line
there are enough people moving about
that no one sees me enter the group I
can see my sisters and they have a spot
for me to slide into I feel a sense of
freedom for the first time in a long
time suddenly I know I am strong and
brave it is as though an angel is
looking after me I think as I look
upward
maybe it's my mother who helps me out of
this terrible situation maybe things
will get better for us now I make eye
contact with hi you saw her she has
sheer joy on her face as I approached
she elbows you key to indicate that I am
on my way over as I end of a line Yuuki
immediately grabs my arm and squeezes it
so tight all of us are frightened and
excited at the same time hi you saw her
you ki are relieved that I am with them
and even have even a little surprise
that I made it I can see the questions
on their faces but silently indicate we
can't talk about it now I will explain
how I did this later when we are alone
the three of us try to act calm so no
one will notice that I am not supposed
to be in line I feel their hands as
tight as I can so tight that I can't
feel my own fingers we have to celebrate
internally and happiness springs up
inside me hope and fear war within me
before leaving the camp for the factory
we need to go through a cleaning process
we now we know we all smell I remember
when I first came to camp I smelled a
sour pungent odor everywhere
on everyone I guess I've smelled it for
so long now that I don't notice it
anymore
but you can only see the revulsion on
the faces of new prisoners when they
arrive it is the stench of death on
living bodies I can see the dirt in the
lines on people's faces our hands don't
come clean when we rinse them the hair
that grew back in the last four months
is stuck to our heads and has a foul
odor it is clear to me that we are not
supposed to have been here this long but
now that time will end if I can make it
through the cleaning without being
labeled a Muslimin so once again talking
about your courage yes to do that it was
unbelievable how this all came to me how
I did it I don't I don't remember but I
did it the main thing was to get out of
there and some time you have to do you
have to do all kinds of things okay to
get what you want to go and also you
should never give up hope without hope
you're lost so whenever you're in
anybody's in trouble they have to
remember that things will get better and
that's how we survived the three of us
you guys get cleaned up they shave you
again
they delouse you full of life they
didn't have cleaning in four months can
you imagine no in four months actually I
took my dress up a couple of times in
the summer because we you know we were
also lucky that we were there in the
summer not in the winter if we would
have been there in the winter we would
have frozen to death so we were there in
summary so I would take my dress off and
wash it
there was no soap know nothing and let
it dry and then put it back on
you say hey after after you get D Loused
and cleaned you say this finally we are
giving decent street street clothes -
where is the first time in four months
I've changed my clothes
one of the women pins a piece of paper
with a number on it to my dress she
tells me that this will be my number
that identifies me from now on
they've taken away my name I am no
longer Rosie
or even a Schwartz now I am just a
number a 2 5 8 9 3 yep
see yet mm-hmm you know a lot of the
survivors after the war they had taken
off but in you know in the 50s surgery
wasn't like today they would always have
a mark on their arms you know and never
to me I never even occurred to me to do
that and my kids were little they would
ask me what it is I would tell him it's
my telephone number they process you now
and get you loaded onto a truck that
drives you guys out of the camp and you
say as we pass through the gates I feel
an incredible weight lifted off my
shoulders this is truly a moment to
remember I know that my life may not be
easier at the work Factory but at least
we are alive we are scared and weak but
we have left the hell about what's
behind us at the factory they provide us
with more decent street clothes similar
what I previously owned the building is
so cold so we go to bed fully dressed
even our blankets are not enough to keep
us warm but at least we have blankets
the building has a musty odor but I have
my own bed with a mattress sheets
blanket and pillow we are allowed to
access bathrooms at night we can even
get a shower with soap and you're even
given clean clothes once a week the
showers and bathroom are just down the
hall compared to the hell of a sweat
stone this feels like heaven so this is
your your new location right and it
really is this is what you've been
striving for to get into the one of
these work yes did you know that the
work camp was better living or were you
just knowing that anything is better
than house which we didn't know but
everything anything was better than now
it's okay I don't think there could be
any worse than our Schmitz
on our first day of work the numbers
that were pinned to our clothes are
tattooed onto our left forearms I know
that I should feel pain but I don't as I
watch them scratch the needle across my
skin in my mind I am thinking about the
law that Jews may not take make any
cuttings or print any marks on their
bodies how will God take this new
development I'm not in any position to
resist the permanent tattoo that reminds
me every single day that I am NOT free a
2 5 8 9 3 is emblazoned for the world to
see every time I reach my hand out to
touch my sister or grab a piece of
machinery each day as we leave the
factory we show our tattoo
which confirms that we are Jews who
belong in the camp and not one of the
free citizens that goes home at night so
when you're working this camp there's
actually regular civilians that are
working there right Germans or the
Germans Germans absolutely and mostly
women because all the men wear them but
in the military wording yes you say this
sometimes the German lady who works next
to me brings me an apple yes is a big
risk for her to offer me any special
treatment because she could be labeled
as a Jewish sympathizer and be taken to
jail or shot it is also a risk for me
because I can be labeled to thief there
are no apples given a Jews here so how
would I get one it would be up to a
guard to decide my fate if I were caught
with an apple we are very careful that
no one of authority is around when she
hands me the Apple I think she realizes
how hard our lives aren't feels a bit
sorry for me it is so good to see the
humanity in some people because we have
lived for months and some of us for
years
surrounded by inhuman and savage guards
every day we have been treated as though
we are not human so this is like the
first sympathetic person right she was
very nice did you have conversations
with her you talked to her we would not
have conversations not too much no
because we were both working at
different things but she but she but she
would bring an extra piece of something
sometimes an apple or a soother
even though
compared to Auschwitz this was like
Haman okay you Yuki was in an area
working on ammunition it's you to come
Utica
so sorry Yuka Yuka you get well how
about how am I doing with you how you
solder bad how do you say how you solder
hiya sorta are you sir
that's a Yiddish name how you sorry
Helen Helen her English name was Helen
or in Czech it was Helen car okay I need
to stick with one she's sewing Yuka yes
is working on ammunition and you're
working our gas masks i inspecting gas
masks which is obviously a hard thing
because you're thinking these gas masks
are for german soldiers it's gonna say
absolutely absolutely but we had no
choice i would sit on a high chair coin
and then have to pick up the guests get
gas masks look inside it and put it down
up and down twelve hours every day or so
and judy and judy my sister Trudy and my
sister Helen one of them worked on
uniforms and one of them worked on guns
we were all in different areas it was a
big factory over there you know this
this idea that you had of sticking
together of being a family and how that
increases your chances for survival I as
I read that it seemed a little bit
counterintuitive to me because I always
think well if I just have to take care
of myself it seems like you'd be able to
make more things happen as opposed to
you're looking out for other people but
what I failed to realize and what I
think is that because you're sticking
together you're looking out for each
other you're keeping you know maybe you
give a little bit of extra bread you
share some bread so you're able to take
care of each other at people that went
by themselves had less of a chance to
survive absolutely absolutely
a lot of women that came there to our
camp that were alone I would say most of
them didn't make it
being alone is so hard but then you have
you are with sisters you know at least
you have more hope to survive you say
here I'm always afraid that if I attract
the attention of the guards they will
realize I'm too skinny to work and will
kill me then who will help my sisters
stay together I have to stay alive and
do his Tata said after a month the
factory I gather the courage to speak to
the person in charge I take a deep
breath before approaching the
intimidating officer my hands shake as
he looks down at me I am still very
short for my 14 years and with no heels
or hair to help me seem taller I'm sure
I look like a younger child this is hard
work I say shock that out confident my
voice sounds because my hands are
shaking I press them into my sides
hoping you won't notice I should get an
extra meal to conserve my strength to my
utter surprise the officer allows me an
extra meal each day yes I would take it
to the living quarters and I would share
it with my sisters over time my sisters
and I realized that the German doctors
in white coats conduct experiments on
the prisoners I don't remember the
incident but my sisters tell me I was
taken by one of the doctors for several
hours upon my return my mouth remained
painful for several days I asked my
sisters to look at my mouth to find out
why it was so sore they noticed that all
my teeth are drilled out and filled with
something grey that looks like Street
cement I cannot see inside my mouth
because we have no mirrors but I had no
fillings in my teeth before coming to
the factory the procedure is so awful I
blocked it out it takes weeks for the
pain to subside yeah so that just a
random yeah you get taken away right I
may have complained that I had some pain
in my teeth I'm not really sure about
that all I know is when we were
liberated I had my teeth filled with
cement
our daily lives contend this is
fast-forwarding a bit and again people
have to get the book to read it to get
all the all the details which are
incredible to read harrowing to read
yeah but I'm gonna fast forward it but
you say our daily lives continue as each
and every day we wake each work walk
back to our quarters wash eat and sleep
it seems like a never-ending monotony
but we are grateful for it
this routine feels safe al Schwartz had
no predictability since any situation
could turn into a nightmare in a second
safety is rare these days so we embraced
as much as possible
the guards mostly leave us alone unless
someone steps out of line hardly any as
any of us do that anymore because we all
recognize there is safety in submission
going forward a little bit more and
again you you you tell some really
really kind of fascinating stories about
what goes on inside and and people need
to get the book to see those to read
about those I'm gonna fast forward but
after eight months of working and living
at the factory something starts to
change I start to feel eyes watching me
steadily I've known that the guards
watch us but never felt this kind of
observation I can feel their eyes on me
watching like a hawk waiting for me to
make a mistake I think they are planning
to take me back to the camp and to my
death one day I'm looking through the
glass of a gas mask when Rivka payors in
front of me in front of my distorted
glass I'm so startled that I jump off my
stool what are you doing they will see
you I kiss her she should not leave her
place of the line surely a guard will
discover her and we will both get in
trouble have you heard she asked in a
whisper
heard what I asked confused no one has
spoken to me at all day autumn all at
all today
apart from my supervisor who barks
orders that up at us once every hour we
are to be marched she says gravely I
have no idea what she means by that but
from her face I know it is not good
marched where by whom I don't know I
heard some God's guards talking about
how the Russians are coming she replies
the word Russians makes my heart feel
makes my heart beat faster I know that
they are fighting against the Germans
for liberation but what does liberation
look like no one knows
we know is that right now the Russians
are the only people who want to get us
out of this prison
on May 6 1945 we wake up to a gray
gloomy morning and prepare for work
there is an odd energy running through
the room as we make our way to the door
to line up I wonder why everyone is so
jittery are there extra guards outside
are they moving us are we going on the
March we line up and from in front of
the door like always but instead of the
silence that usually permeates the air
whispers fly along the line what is
happening someone asks are they sending
us back to the camps I don't know where
the guards they should be here by now
another person answers one brave souls
ventures one brave soul ventures to the
door after about 15 minutes all of us
are nervous she opens the door and we
see no one the usually locked door
swings open without resistance we
cautiously move out to the yard to find
the gates to our quarters wide open this
has never happened before and all of us
are very worried we look around for the
guards as we walk toward the gate there
on the fence is a plain white bed sheet
someone wrote on it in German it reads
there will be no work for a few days
there will be a March that all of you
will be in wait here until we come for
you I didn't even remember that scene
that well I know I said the guards
didn't come to walk us to the factory ok
and after being hours and hours away
after we were waiting all these hours I
said to my sisters I'm going out I want
to see what's going on
I was probably the youngest kid in the
group we were 300 women I believe I go
outside and the offense the gate to the
fence because we had electric fences
surrounding us was wide open the Germans
run away everybody run away and of
course Here I am and all the women are
in the building they're all afraid to
come out and I'm screaming at them
actually coming out I think the SS all
ran away and I hear the planes going
over us and I hear the shooting up
because
behind but we were living they had all
kinds of cornfields they were growing a
lot of corn the Russians were coming
through the cornfields and they came and
so and I saw that of course I said I
better go in front of the Russians but
how am I gonna go you know they might
think I'm German because I had hair
already the same sized hair like and
regular clothes and so being I guess my
hair was not that big that long okay
they might but we did not have any any
marks on our dresses saying who we are
okay but I thought that maybe they think
I'm German okay so I thought a piece of
my dress up and I found a stick and I
put that down I went in front of the
Russians like this there what was their
reaction
oh they hugged me and kissed me I mean
and I told them we have the 300 women
here they came they liberated us and it
was an amazing day did you I mean at
that point were you how long did it take
you to realize that that this was this
was the end of everything you've been
through well we've been looking forward
to this for so long it finally happened
okay you may you stayed with your
sisters the whole time right absolutely
oh yeah I don't know if I would have
survived without my sisters I don't know
if my sisters would have survived
without me because I did things that
nobody did you know in a condition in a
situation like this you have to do
certain things to survive okay you say
in the book this is the moment we had
dreamed of hoped for and waited long
months to see you as well as wonderful
as any of the dreams I had all of us
were overjoyed at the news we waited so
long to hear Helen
Judy and I are survivors right we are
finally free
we stayed together like Tonto said
because it would improve our chance to
survive that he was right yeah that the
Russians tell you hey go out into town
take what you want right they did but I
didn't go alone I went with the Russians
the Russian soldiers came to our living
quarters and they would offer their help
they were very good for us to us and
were the were their Germans still in the
houses or were they gone
oh no they left are you kidding they ran
away as soon as the Russians they saw
the Russians they all fled so you're
just going from no food no clothes and
all of a sudden you're got normal food
and everything right away no food after
that no no but the Russians were very
good too I say took us into town and and
they also brought food for us if we
needed anything they would get it for us
so you um you eventually decide that
you're gonna head back to your home
village of course you say after four
weeks on the trains we finally arrive
and walk to our little farm our once
beautiful and cozy home is hardly
recognizable the roof is almost gone
likely from a bomb all our belongings
are gone
they must have housed German horses in
it since there was horsemen or
everywhere I remember we're tots I hid
the jewelry and I rushed to find it I am
relieved to find the spot is untouched
even though the roof is largely gone
I caught the mud to uncover the shoebox
when my fingertips tap a corner of the
box I rapidly removed the mud to extract
it relieved that it remained
undiscovered I climbed down to show you
key and how you solder
I sort of highest suited high you solder
yes we sit down on our kitchen floor to
carefully open the lid inside his top
does pocket watch chain which is the one
you're wearing right my parents wedding
rings earrings and a couple of gold
chains all of us cry at the discovery
these are the only things that remain
from our past
you start to get you start to get news
you start to get rumors and information
one man reported that he knew nothing of
Tata but was in a camp with fishel where
they were where they sewed SS uniforms
he described how well my brother didn't
camp just days before the end of the war
all 300 men in his camp were marched
into the forest and forced to dig a
large hole the Germans then stood them
all at the edge of the hole and shot
them yeah as they fell into the hole it
became a mass grave the man told me that
the Germans goal is to destroy any proof
of what they did during the war so they
made sure that there would be no
survivors to talk about what happened in
the camps yeah I asked the man how he
survived if everyone else died he tells
me that he was too ill to get up so he
hid in the back of the barracks and no
one noticed him poor fishel came within
days of liberation only to be
slaughtered by the Nazis later another
local man returns with news of our
father this man was with Tata in a
factory where Tata had become very sick
he had sores on his legs and that would
not heal because Tata did not recover
and could not work they shipped him back
to Auschwitz where he was murdered I
repeatedly think about him and the
injustice wondering if he was scared
my brave intelligence for intelligent
father's face swims in my mind I wonder
if he thought of us before he died I'm
sure he did sure he did
the fate of our immediate family is now
clear of the 11 Schwartz family members
taken there are only three who survived
over time we get word of our extended
family our wonderful family of nearly
150 is reduced to only 11 survivors
unfortunately yet I maybe may have been
more than 150 people because in those
days you know Jewish families they they
they did not believe in contraceptives
they didn't use those and so everybody
had a lot of kids and my mother and my
father they each had three or four or
maybe five sisters and brothers so and
the only ones that came back maybe it
does nervous and we know of there may
have been other survivors and many men
may not know about okay they lived in
different places because in those days
it was not much when you lived in
different cities we did not keep in
touch too much
so you hear about the central British
fund right and they have a program where
they're taking orphaned survivor
children from the Holocaust and bringing
them to England right and you apply for
this program and this is they it says so
they're called the CF CBF despite the
CBF's attempt to gather a thousand
survivor orphans they can only locate
732 kids right On February 19 1946 I
joined the last transport of survivors
to load into a Royal Air Force planes
David all bomber planes used to use but
transporting us the first transport
started in August of 1945 and the last
transport was 1946 of February 12 Sen I
was in the last transport and so with it
there was only 732 yes that's all they
could find yes or only that registered
for the program mm-hmm so maybe they
were more but we'd I didn't I don't know
why they didn't register so you fly
across and you end up in Scotland
Scotland at the point in the house right
unless made just called les major you
say here in this unexpected start to a
new life we have no parents and most of
us have no siblings but we have each
other we all stick together we become
like family this simple life falls into
pattern of predictable safe days which
comforts all of us we are encouraged to
have fun and relax together all of us
are equal to eager to feel normal again
with our new family our days are routine
and comforting the counselors talk to us
about our new life and what to expect
now we need a long-term plan
the only plans we had this hopefully
maybe going getting coming to America
we're going to Israel okay because all
our city said we came from they were
little pet in the past when um like I
said there's both both you and Max have
sections in this book and the Max's
section describes what he went through
right and you know it's a similar start
and edict is nailed to the trees around
the village that all Jews to report to
the nearby ghetto his dad does a pretty
good maneuver where he basically bribes
one of the Germans and says hey my
family can work all of us can work and
gets the whole family sent to commando
flossenbürg which is a forest laborer
company and he says they they go into
this kind of self-contained all Jewish
work camp and even though they don't get
paid like they're not being tortured
they vie view this as a good thing that
they're in this forced labour camp right
they need that labor also he works there
for about a year and then they get told
that they're going to get moved so they
have to break down all the equipment
that they're using in his factory they
loaded onto trucks they move it from the
trucks to to a salt mine which was a bad
decision by the Germans because inside
the salt mine all the equipment starts
to rust almost immediately so they have
to break it down and pack it up again
which they do and
then they get shipped off again I'll
read this little section here soon after
donning our blue and white uniform we
enter a long line that moves very slowly
each person exits the front of the line
I can see them examining their forearm
one man shows us his forearm and blurts
and Yiddish they are tattooing these
letters on our arms how will God view
this he must be an Orthodox Jew our
faith forbids us to have tattoos in this
moment I am thankful that we are not
Orthodox and were raised to be more
relaxed about our faith I can see the
pain on the man's face data shows him
God would never punish you for something
you cannot control the tattoo on his
forearm says KL I intend to find out
what that means so we are waiting in
line for a tattoo I wonder why we did
tattoo here if we didn't need one at the
last camp this new camp is worse in so
many ways already dad and the other men
quickly find out from the inmates that
KL is shortened from the word
concentration lager concentrates yeah
which means concentration concentration
camp right the tattoo identifies us as
prisoners of a concentration camp
dad feared we would end up here so max
ends up in a work as a worker ends up
since he's small he's only 14 years old
ends up working inside of airplane wings
he says the poles hate us and will not
help us in any way because the he once
again he's working alongside of Polish
people the normals normal polish
civilians
every night we lay on the straw teeming
with lice and bedbugs there are 300 boys
and men per barrack all of whom are
suffering the same challenges bug mite
the bug bites make it difficult to sleep
at night and in daytime they cause itchy
irritation in addition we must wear the
same uniform for a month before we get a
new one getting rid of the bugs is
impossible sanitation in the case labor
camp is awful there is a cold water
trough where we rinse our hands and face
there's no soap there are no showers
latrines or pits with a wooden board
over them the board has a round opening
for us to squat over but there's no
toilet paper so many people use the
latrine it always stinks Jewish inmates
are assigned to clean it in fact I
realize now that Jews are doing all the
work in the camp the guards are just
directing them lunch is a bowl of soup
dinner is three or four ounces of bread
everyone in the camp is weak and
malnourished we go to work no matter
what
everyone knows prisoners who cannot work
are shot or sent to the gas chamber
didn't keep us there to have a good time
ends up in another concentration camp
called Plaza Plaza rush of flash off the
rumen in the camp is that the Russians
are now close to Warsaw and are
threatening to override the Germans the
Allies are coming Poland and Germany are
bracing for attack the soldiers here are
more tense than at the other camps we
need to be very careful not to test
their patience because they become more
explosive with every little provocation
now at this camp we are to do work not
in a factory instead we move around the
city to dig ditches and build
fortifications for the German troops
once again your do you're doing
something that's gonna help the people
that are that are torturing you and
killing you we have no choice
ends up getting moved again and again
you got to read this book to to get this
story I'm going through the hot the high
points of it right now
or the low points I guess but in the end
he gets transport again and ash wits is
the destination but the train comes to
rest in near Dresden we remain at this
location for nearly a year we work in
the factory our work in the factory is
consistent and comfortably predictable
we hear with increasing frequency that
from the grapevine that the Allies are
closer even some of the local Germans
talk about what will happen if allies
enter Dresden the night of February 13
1945 the Allies saturation bombing of
Dresden begins the sky lights up with
flares from the first wave of planes
subsequent waves of bombers dropped
phosphorus bombs that cause fires after
exposing the entire cities become a
giant torch when our factory housing
gets hit fire spreads quickly
pandemonium breaks out as we prisoners
run down the stairs to the bomb shelters
the words survived survive survive
repeat in my head like a comforting
chant two days later the bombing is
finally over when we crawl out of the
bomb shelter we see that the factory is
half gone and the accommodations
upstairs for the inmates is lost we must
now sleep with no roof it's literally
freezing temperatures and we have no
blankets so yeah that's some that's the
the bombing of Dresden tonight which was
a historical you know that's they bombed
with these incendiary bombs which caught
fire and I want to say 250,000 people
were killed in those in that and not
bombing penalty and a lot of civilians
mostly civilians and you know people
look at that in various different ways
but at this point in the war it was a
decision that was made I think Churchill
really drew
that decision because the Germans the
Nazis had been bombing and killing
civilians in England and he said okay
well yep and that's what they did and a
curse Kurt Vonnegut's
slaughterhouse-five book is about coming
out of the coming out of the P o W camps
prisons prison camps after that as well
because everything was just destroyed by
bombing that city for two days he gets
moved around again and yeah they go on a
they get marched right they go on and I
got I got to read this section after a
few days the German SS soldiers with
their guns on their soldiers roundup the
commando group this is them
the commando frozen burg group again and
we set off on a forced march we are 300
to 350 men marching through the forest
into Czechoslovakia the March takes a
few weeks but feels more like a year and
it is ghastly for our group we march on
one side of the river watching bombs
explode on the other side with snow on
the ground all of us are freezing as we
climb up the mountains I can't feel my
toes and try to walk with my hands
tucked into my armpits we get very
little to eat and we are all starving we
marched through several towns as people
stand on the side of the road and
silently watch
we are told not to speak to the
townspeople or accept anything from them
or else we will be shot
not one person offers us anything no
food or jackets or boots or blankets it
is a disastrous death march from
bombed-out Dresden to little me Reese I
see men fall give up and die or sit down
and refuse to go on these people are all
shot dad's health declines and he is in
bad shape he is very weak and cannot
walk alone Fred and I support him on
either side with his arms over over our
shoulders we get tired after hours of
assisting him with other men when we get
tired
after hours of assisting him other men
from our group help hold him up the
German stuff us in a barn in a barn in a
sub camp our first two nights after the
death march at long last we are given a
small amount of food which is our first
food in 8 to 10 days
we sleep on the dirt floors squashed
together to try and stay warm
our first night's sleep in almost 10
days no one cares about the important
living conditions and we are completely
exhausted and barely alive two days
later when we arrive at the ghetto in
late March of 1945 there are only about
80 of our group who are still alive
after the forced death march the rest
are dead out of 300
so I mean at this point they're they're
put into another cameo max says here
everyone is near death completely
exhausted and starving the camp is
overcrowded filthy and disorganized they
get marched to a place called The Fault
the small fortress which was just
another nightmarish hell on May 8th and
again I'm skipping forward but you've
got to get this book to read through
what actually happened on May 1945
Soviet troops enter the small fortress
to liberate the camps a dead Asian stop
what is that the name of the town
Terezin could this be the day we have
waited so long for the troops are indeed
here to liberate us our imprisonment at
the hands of the Germans is over at last
even the weakest of us is celebrating to
know we are finally finally free we did
survive we are no longer captives
prisoners and slaves to the German Nazis
the three of us so it's max Fred End and
the dad their dad despite all the odds
have survived to today's liberation
although dad is very likely at death's
door yeah I can now proudly wear dad's
gold watch-chain rather than hide it and
again there's a incredible story and
it's a it's a similar story to yours in
that your death Max's dad had a chain
except for max kept it with him the
whole time and him and his brother Fred
traded it back and forth and kept it and
hid it over all that time now he's able
to take that watch chain out and
actually wear it he says this we slowly
came to the realization that dad did not
survive the typhus epidemic Fred and I
share along knowing look we both know I
can see it in his eyes Benjamin
Schindler is dead after a quiet period
we begin talking about what likely
happened
I hope that dad lived long enough to
know liberation Fred believes this is
true he says after liberation people
wander around looking confused relieved
and angry and all have questions about
their loved ones makes them Fred they
were they were came down with typhoid so
they kept them six weeks in one place
and by the time they came out of this
disease they could get up and go outside
they looked for the father and there was
no where couldn't find him anywhere so a
lot of people that a lot of people died
after liberation and they buried a lot
of people in Terezin but they had no
names because none of us had names in
the camps I mean when we were in terror
sea and in frightened I'll be had the
names but we didn't have it on our
clothes or anything so most camps no you
didn't have the names on your clothes or
anything there's no way to identify oh
wait I didn't know family to identify so
when someone died it was just uh that's
it nameless body right so that's what
happened to makes his father he says
here with the help of the Red Cross we
find out that mom and Cecilia went to
student off she's too tall for camp in
East Prussia that concentration camp
reportedly expanded several times adding
more barracks and extermination chambers
during the war they tell us that rich
ella ella and cecilia gender Schindler
were killed there just before liberation
all surviving inmates were loaded onto
barges pushed out into the baltic sea
and were deliberately sunk our worst
fear is realized we worried about mom
and Cecilia's safety every day we were
suffering in the camps keeping hope
alive that they would survive learning
with certainty that they are dead is a
tremendous blow the Red Cross is also
investigated the Red Cross also
investigated our family in Poland that
went into the ghetto they tell us that
our cousins aunts on
chuckles and grandma shread saying the
right choice ride were all killed none
of them survived we also find out that
our dear grandpa Schindler refused to go
into a ghetto when the Jews were rounded
up in 1942 he was shot in the street
near his home a ninety years old he
refused to leave his home we now know
that our whole family is gone murdered
by the German Nazis dad is dead mom and
cecilia are gone our extended family no
longer exists it is just Fred and me in
the world all that remains from our
former life is the gold chain that dad
wore to hold his watch it's not an easy
book to read that was not I've read it
so many times and yet every time I break
out in tears I can't help it I mean both
both to to to hear and read about both
of your family and Max's family the
entire family's gone for no reason just
because they were Jewish the world
doesn't realize what they've lost who
knows maybe one of those people could
have been the doctor who would have
found a cure for cancer
okay because we believe a lot of in
education okay
max finds out about the same program
that you were enrolled into of looking
for orphan survivors and the maximum age
for that group is 16 Fred is 17 so Fred
max decides they're gonna lie about
their ages to get in there yeah
we had no IDs we had nothing we had was
the clothes on our bodies nothing else
no identification of any kind so max you
know max gets to England and again you
just got to read the book to go through
that transition of what it's like to go
from a from a concentration camp to
England right with white sheets and
white bread and he he's got a part of
there where he explains he thinks white
bread is basically like cake he thinks
they're making sandwiches on cake
because it tastes so delicious to him
yeah just just it's a really it's just
powerful and you know one of the things
that I I called out in here is that he
says we attend school we attended
organization and rehabilitation and
training school for half a day five days
a week the school is designed to prepare
us for life and work and and you know I
just read that as his focus and it seems
like everyone's focus was like okay
we're gonna move forward we gotta find a
new job we got to find out how we're
gonna put our lives together you have to
do that if you don't you're lost and
there's also what's the UM name of mr.
Montefiore am I saying that right I'm on
the feudal and what was his position he
was a wealthy Jewish philanthropist in
London and he offered to take us to
England he was kind of supplying a lot
of financial backing behind absolutely
yes actually sir Leonard
the bureau walked me down the aisle room
we got married in London because I had
no parents and so he offered to do that
ya know that's why I definitely wanted
to call out his name because I knew he
was an important figure oh yes he was a
very important person in England and
very important person in Israel when you
have you ever been to Israel I have not
in Israel many of the cities have a lot
of certain liner Monty Fury's all over
the place but she built this and he
built that and all kinds of things you
guys there's there's a great line in
here again you know it's this the
counselors tell us that we did not
deserve the suffering that we endured
that it cannot stop us now and that any
that we can be anything we want to if we
are willing to work hard ranked which is
just you know again the the mentality of
look we've got to move forward and also
it's interesting you can be anything you
want but you still have to be willing to
work hard even after everything you've
been through you're still gonna have to
get out there and absolutely and we did
and we did all of us let me tell you
something if you're gonna count all the
survivors that's that remained from all
the people that were killed and that
came to this United States okay I bet
you not one would have gone on welfare
because the first thing they did get a
job okay
our education was very low I mean I had
three and a half years Abed you came
close to four years of education I never
even thought of going back to school and
wasn't even on my mind
first of all in Europe we only had
education till the age of fourteen even
though I didn't have it in Europe
because we couldn't go after I was like
nine years old but we all work very hard
to get where we are okay
you do a you do a great job of going
through like kind of how all this stuff
unfolds and it's it's really just a
beautiful part of the book when you
there's five of you girls that show up
in where is it Bedford hostel and it's a
bunch of a bunch of the young men
survivors that's when you uh well that's
when you that's when you meet one
handsome young gentleman who says hello
I'm max this is my brother Fred yeah
welcome to Bedford and when I saw him I
said I'm gonna marry him you made the
call huh I made the call
plus he already had a girlfriend because
all the girls from Bedford the town the
non-jewish girls he would come to the to
the hostel they liked the Jewish boys so
you had to I had to it took me some time
but I got him test your patience right
that's what you need to do in life but
you gotta go after what you want
gonna take a little risk sometimes
coming from Rose you uh you uh you get
jobs you learn English now you move to
London who is it that moves to London is
it this is it you max and Fred that all
moved to London together yes yes we did
and because the hostel was closing the
kids were leaving they were finding
relatives in the United States they're
going to Israel they're going to
Australia you know because we had all
orphans and a lot of us remembered we
had relatives here there and everywhere
okay so a lot of them so a lot of us
from England you know came to England
and then we went over to the United
States and you are you guys get married
you say it when you guys get married
your receptions 95% of the guests are
survivors in the hall all survivors we
kind of stuck together mm-hmm
you know what I mean yeah the veteran
hostels together and then even when we
came to London we did not live in a
hostel day you know they put us in
private homes in there
would pay for our upkeep you uh you go
on now honeymoon is it a honeymoon when
you guys go to Paris yes you say I never
thought I could be this happy again
after all we lived through in the camps
as we head back to England I think of my
parents and wonder if they were ever
this happy thinking of my parents makes
me miss them for a moment and I am sad
but then we arrive at our destination of
the thaad sad thoughts are pushed aside
in favor of hope for the future this is
just such a common theme that you talk
about all the time that you're not going
to get caught up in the past and it's
not that you're gonna forget about the
past but you're not gonna dwell there
right well you cannot get the you cannot
life is to look forward for better
things I mean if you're going to look
for the past all the time it's not gonna
get you anywhere okay so we just have to
hope for the best and do the best we can
you say here London is a fun city for us
we have lots of friends and enjoy our
jobs five years have flown by since
leaving the hostel and we are so happy
for our new life here together and again
I'm fast-forwarding through a bunch of
really really good stuff and then you
say one night over a wonderful dinner of
fish and chips max proclaims Rose I
think it's time for us to move to
America his statement takes me by
surprise max periodically talked about
moving to America since we met we talked
about America as a destination for some
day but I never considered that some day
might be today he told me that his
father had been trying to get the family
immigration visas before the Germans
rounded up all the Jews I don't know max
what we do in America whatever we want
he tells me with a smile so that was
your vision of America night was we're
gonna go there and yes that was our hope
the uncle I had he didn't offer to bring
us but Max's family offered to bring us
send us affidavits okay
the affidavits for their to come to
America so they just got a sign that hey
we're gonna responsible for your okay
they were responsible for us for five
years okay so of course when we came to
America we spoke perfect English already
within 34 days we had jobs land of
opportunities and ever put your lots of
opportunities here right although I I
thought well maybe you can expand on
this a little bit because well first of
all October 30 1951 Rose and I this is
max max talking rose and I we're both
where our fathers watch chains as we
leave the apartment when we reach New
York City on October 12th my uncle and
second cousins meet us at the dock and
put us up in a Manhattan hotel for two
nights our hotel window looks out into a
junkyard which makes us want to check
out as soon as possible
after a quick breath breakfast on our
second full day in America my uncle
gives us $20 and says good luck you're
on your own right from then on we will
never stay in family again I do not feel
we need them we can make it here in
America on our own as long as Rose and I
have each other
I tell you very lucky to have these
relatives okay makes us family they were
really amazing people okay and we loved
each other deeply okay they welcomed us
like their own kids thank God we never
needed their help so he gets a job at a
scale company working on making making
scales and then he notices some some
little up growing company called
International Business Machines
or IBM realizes maybe that could be a
good job he gets involved in that you
end up passing out one time on the train
get to go to the doctor and then and
then Max says when Rose calls me the
next day she tells me there's nothing at
all to worry about excitedly she says
the doctor says that there's only one
thing going on with me and that is that
I am pregnant
right
19:55 max decides he's going to come and
check out a little place called San
Diego California we all know what
happens when you come to San Diego first
nobody wants to do it once we max
included and then you arrived in april
of nineteen fifty six baby roxanne and
then you end up with a place in North
Park you get a job at Golden State
fabrics right and then you start you
start raising your family yeah Ben
arrives in 1957 who I met today mm-hmm
it was a second I have a daughter who is
65 years old and Ben is 62 so we came to
San Diego in 1956 I came to send max
came Christmastime first he came for the
three-day visit and he never went back
to New York it calls me two days later
he says Rose we're moving to San Diego
we got a job at so large okay okay and
worked for so loud for five years and
then he went to General Dynamics he
retired after working at General
Dynamics for 28 years
good good a good career and a great
place to settle down so we lived in
Norfolk for six months and then we
bought a house in LA Gardens you don't
you know I'm gonna take a little aside
here you say this you say occasionally I
still wonder if there is a God how could
there be with all the terror that
happened to us and to others surely God
would not have allowed it when I think
about this it makes me angry I asked
myself why God would have allowed the
Holocaust to happen and I'd never come
up with an answer
I cannot sort out with what I feel so
this question has to be put aside to
allow me to continue with all the good
in my life
that's a very big question losing so
many people complete families wiped out
there are so many complete families
wiped out
you know I the one woman that talked to
you inside Auschwitz that said you will
never make any sense of this because it
doesn't make any sense like this is too
insane to understand right it's too you
can't comprehend it cuz it's
incomprehensible it is I mean we're
sitting here talking about you know you
and your direct family and then you
multiply it times two to get you and
your direct family and Max and his
direct family but then you have to do
that hundreds and hundreds and hundreds
of times over and over again and every
one of those unidentified bodies that
got buried in a mass grave with no
identification at no family every one of
those and you know this is something I
talk about a lot because it happens in
war all the time oh there was there was
a 22 soldiers killed oh there was you
know 428 soldiers killed on this attack
in World War one those aren't just
soldiers you know those are people it's
not and these people these bodies
unidentified bodies every one of them
had a family yeah hopes max convinces it
sounds like he kind of convinced his
Fred to come out and move to move to
California it sounds like Fred had a
harder time after he did he did he had a
harder time he lost his hair in the camp
so after liberation his hair never came
back and he was more a lot of people are
more obsessed from the past the best
thing is some time to forget some you
know not to think always about the past
because you want to go ahead yeah thing
that I talk to people when I talk about
loss right because I've lost a lot of
friends and when people ask me about how
they handle that I tell them to remember
but don't dwell so we never want to
forget what happened but we don't want
to as you're saying we don't want to sit
there in the past because we need to
think about the future value move
forward
Mac says we don't really talk about the
camp's much at all our friends don't
want to hear about the atrocities and we
don't want to relive them even in our
survivors group it's not a big subject
it is difficult to talk about losing
absolutely everything your home your
family everything you own even your
family photos for most Jewish families
the only people to survive are those who
left Europe or hid our circumstances are
rare even rose and I have an unspoken
agreement not to speak of it between us
we both understand and do not need to
talk about it we are focused on going
forward right looking ahead and working
on everything together that's that's
what life is all about when you talked
about again just just Max's career then
he said and he's one of the things that
he said about his career he said I want
my children to see that anything is
possible with determination hard work
and an eagerness to learn right
if max if the world wouldn't have been
affecting max so badly I mean his whole
family he would have been really
something very special it was a very
smart man I mean also we have no
education there were a lot of big plans
for the Schindler boys and before the
ball okay
of course it all went to hell when you
your son Steve's 13 years old and tell
us about what happened there that kind
of kind of changed the direction of your
life a little bit well he was in the pn
frank story and he played the part of
peter okay and the teacher found out
that his parents are Holocaust survivors
at Lois junior high and allied gardens
and that's when I started speaking about
the Holocaust before we didn't want to
talk about it okay because life goes on
and so we didn't want to even tell our
kids a lot about what happened so when
when Steve was in this play they started
calling me to go and talk about the
Holocaust so that's and I've been
speaking there that it's close to fifty
years now Steve is 62 no he's six he's
no excuse me he's 60 Ben is 62 Steve is
gonna be 64 next month so you can
imagine how many years I've been
speaking about the Holocaust well one
thing that you said in here that I think
really is a bold statement you say the
Germans did not succeed in their
endeavor to silence the Jews or prevent
anyone from telling their of their
atrocities I am one of the few who
remain and I can tell the world 82 five
eight nine three on my forearm has a new
value and I am not wanting to pass up an
opportunity this may be my first time
speaking but I will find more places to
share my story that's what you said
after you got done speaking to those
kids for the first time
you were talking to max after you did
the after you talked to the kids 16 yeah
you guys are having this conversation
and this is max talking he says he's
asking you you know what what what were
they asking you about he says what else
did they ask and it says Rose thought
for a moment before responding one child
asked why do I think I survived
Auschwitz
she says softly the fact that a child
asked this is interesting to me
sometimes children say things that
adults won't I know that Rose has
thought about this before so I'm
interested to hear her answer I push a
little further and what was your answer
I asked quietly it's a miracle that I
survived Auschwitz also I really do
think part of it is because I kept
looking out and trying new things I
would not give up I just continued and
never gave up hope as I process her
words she squeezes my hands across the
table and says you did the exact same
thing this takes me aback for a moment
it is true but I've never thought about
my time in the camps in this way before
it really is true that you don't know
when the next attempt that survival
might be the one that succeeds I say I
smile and squeeze her hand back you
really are amazing Rose we got to this
place together max Rose replies before
placing a kiss on my cheek we said
silently for a moment as we both ponder
how our lives could have been different
before this moment is broken I squeezed
her hand to get her attention
we have climbed mountains I did not know
we could climb we made it rose we made
it
yep and um actually as we as we came in
observe us he's gone over three years
now married sixty-seven years
well I think that the incredible life
that you shared together is something
that is a beautiful story and then when
he came in he said he'd been let he said
he'd been listening to the podcast a
little bit to kind of get a get a feel
for it and talk to you a little bit
about what was gonna be like and he was
listen to one of the podcasts and one of
the podcasts what I was saying in the
podcast was keep moving forward like hey
things are gonna be hard you keep moving
forward and he actually brought in a
photograph of of max's tombstone and it
has the single quote that max you know
that that the family decided to put on
the gravestone was live day to day and
keep moving forward
and and I gotta say like I said this
whole thing got started when my wife
wouldn't saw you speak and and just just
looking at this book you you know you
didn't know her at the time but you made
a little inscription to my wife and it
just says Helen never give up hope
signed rose Schindler
and I think that only did I tied that I
wrote that right there no kidding never
give up hope yet never give up yeah so I
mean I think that really between never
give up hope and keep moving forward
those are all very strong sayings strong
sayings and and you and Max are shining
examples of how to actually do that how
to actually do that in life I know I've
had you trapped in here for a while um
you have a website the name of the book
is - who survived - loose if I'm calm
yes there's a website called - who
survived calm the book is available
there the book is available on Amazon
we'll have a link to it so people can
get it through our through our website
to make it easy for them because they
know our podcast website is jockle
podcast you also have social media so
despite the fact that you're not quite a
teenager anymore you still have Twitter
Instagram and Facebook and all those are
are at - who survived it's delet it's
written out t wo who survives and the
book I'm telling you I read a little I
read a fraction the book today there's
so many details in there the stories the
two intertwining stories are so moving
they're so powerful you know and it's
and like I said it reads like a story
reads like it's a it's a real story
exactly what happened and the language
is just it feels like you're sitting
across the table hearing it first
languages actually we did this for
middle school well it was perfect for me
then yes for everybody I guess but we
thought it's so important for us to tell
it to the kids at school what happened
to us okay
yeah it's a it's um it's it's a
beautiful book I mean despite the fact
that it's filled with horror
it still is a beautiful book about about
the strength of that human beings can
display right even in the face of the
evil of other human beings do you have
any uh any closing thoughts Rose because
I I don't want to keep you in here I
want to thank you for doing that I hope
people will enjoy your your story okay
I don't even know where it if I turn on
my it's not a radio I don't even know
what you call it my I'll explain no I'll
explain defend how to get it done well
we have we have since max passed away I
don't even use my great and plotter
radio it's a whole set well I'll make
sure to talk to Bennett so that you can
you can listen to it and watch it
actually be you can watch it too cuz
it'll be on it'll be on something called
YouTube which is Sulekha a television
that you can watch I'm on YouTube
already
yeah well I've watched some of your
stuff you'll be on there more but it's
really funny because I've never even put
on my it's not a radio that I have it's
a whole set like a stereo system stereo
system I should put it on sometime maxi
just max used it all the time but ever
since he passed away things are so
different for me well yeah you know what
I do recommend you go and put the stereo
system on put some records on there yeah
well you should see all the records we
have I bet that max would like to sit
down with you there and listen to some
of those some of those albums so I
recommend you do it okay thank you very
much have a beautiful day yeah you too
and have a beautiful life and just
remember if you have a problem if
something is going not going so well
remember tomorrow is gonna be better
I will do that thank you so much for
coming on thanks for sharing your story
and thank you for forgiving us an
example thank you for doing this okay
it's an honor to have you thank you and
with that Rose Schindler has left the
building
what a what an honor to have her on what
a story pretty unbelievable echo you
made it through yes it's kind of its
kind of harrowing when you think about
it from the perspective of a 9 10 11 12
year-old kid yes right
yeah and there's so there's two things
that I well there's a bunch of things
that I pulled from it but two things
that really stand out small seemingly
small but kind of big where like so they
stuck together you know and so what that
was essentially was covering move yeah
the whole time absolutely because he was
yeah so that was kind of like an you
know how you said it was Connor Connor
into hunger intuitive yeah where it's
like oh yeah like hey if I don't have to
depend on this person or whatever I
identified the root of that thought in
my brain yeah I when I was in Sri Lanka
and I worked closely with their special
operations forces over there there was
an army guy who was saying when he was a
he was a normally infantry commander and
there's a brutal civil war going on in
Sri Lanka
and he was telling me how hard it was to
be in charge and he said listen if I was
alone on the battlefield he goes I will
100% live and do the right thing
100% yeah he says when I got all these
other guys relying on me and making you
know I'm responsible for them he says I
it's so much so much harder and that's
what I was thinking so I was thinking
that hey you if you just if you just got
to take care of yourself it's gonna be
easier but then I thought the same thing
you thought which was wait a second and
that's exactly what I said to her you
know you're taking care of each other
you're covering moving for each other
yeah because that day
where you're hurting that day where you
could use an extra quarter slice of
bread you know maybe you're some morning
your sisters can give it to you and no
one else in the world would so yeah the
the idea of sticking together and having
that and you know obviously like that's
what is that's what the seal platoon is
you know that's what any any team is
right your your your sum is greater the
sum is greater than the parts and that's
what this is a another proof of you know
yeah that was one thing was the other
thing
oh just like there's no real formula to
survive there's like a lot of luck you
know but man her bravery basically was
the function or was the result of just
milking that luck because she was
basically sent to die plenty times but
she would like sneak out of line and do
all this stuff or whatever and that's
like the kind like you just get one
person to see like hey or even realize
you know the kind were you good you know
she goes for selection and they're like
no you're too skinny
you're a muscle man is that what it is
it's funny because it sounds like muscle
man yeah unless it takes one guard to be
like hey wait didn't I just send you to
go die yesterday kind of thing you still
doing here yeah walk with me
yeah I'm gonna make sure this time kind
of thing you know yeah the amount of and
I was thinking about that too you know
how we have well it's literally called
survivor bias right where when you only
hear from the people that made it and it
seems like that's what you should do
because how many thousands of people
said oh I'm gonna sneak out of this line
and they got seen and they got do you
think I killed you know that happened
over and over and over and over again
yeah and it's he I mean you know
according to her like you just do one
single you know sign of resistance
you're like oh they'll just kill you
because like and it makes sense because
it's like not even we need people to
work and obey that's it like otherwise
like you we want love to be not here
yeah if you don't want to do those two
things then we're just gonna kill you in
with no second thoughts whatsoever yeah
yeah and then ya know it's um it is and
isn't it crazy what a human being can
get through you know can't survive and
it makes you realize that we have like
just we are overwhelmed with opportunity
you know even if you consider that
opportunity is just like gonna go home
and drink some water some clean water
I'm gonna go home and clean yourself
yeah gonna go home and not have bed bugs
and lice that's that's the plan that's
what I'm gonna do today when I go home
I'm not gonna have bed bugs and lice
yeah that's that's we got that yeah yeah
right we have food you know leftovers
probably hey let's let's do it you know
there's parts in the book ID like
there's parts in there where she's she
figures out where they've basically
cleaned the dirty kitchen where from
where they make the soup and every once
in a while she can find potato peels
right and she's she has to keep it a
secret because you know she just shares
the potato peels with her sisters only
yeah and if anyone else figures out that
there's potato peels out there there
won't be any like everyone will be there
yeah so so yeah that's the kind of thing
where you think well you're just because
you have sisters it's helpful because
what did the sisters do that helped her
she did that to help the sisters even
there's the time and I know you're
probably feeling this too where where
she or might have been max I forget
which story it was but they went from
the oh yeah when she went to work mmm
right before when they're just in harsh
conditions and then they went to work
and then they could like take a shower
once a week or season Rica with soap
yeah you know when when she you know
when you're going down the list of all
the new things that they had or whatever
when you think about it comparatively
you know - what we have whatever still
like bro those are like slave conditions
really still offer but since you're
cutting engrossed in the story one that
when you started reviewing it I was like
woohoo that's that feels like a relief
even to me you know hearing it but man
that's that's how that's like that
demonstrates you know like how thankful
we should be yeah opportunities
everywhere opportunities and one
opportunity you have is to live yeah
yeah live you're not sitting here
worried about dying no do not worry
about getting hey go in that line over
there by the way you'll be dead in three
minutes that's what's about to happen
yeah do that nine times so well let's
take advantage of the fact that we're
alive is that seems like a good plan
mm-hmm and let's do right what can we do
what can we do to take advantage of the
fact that we're alive right now I'll
tell you we be and remain capable that's
a big deal to capability in health
gratitude is a big one mm-hm obviously
part of that health part of it is
jiu-jitsu obviously and capability to
allows for greater capability
exponentially greater my opinion I would
agree in all aspects yes so anyway a lot
of a lot of us are doing jiu-jitsu a lot
of us are about to do jiu-jitsu
we're gonna need a geek what key do we
get origin gay okay also if you do
noogie get an Origin rash guard the
other part of the uniform in the
totalitarian ki and noogie scenario
that's not really totalitarian but it's
yeah I just learned that mortality is
what you meant totalitarian would mean
there's a regime that's not what I mean
at all
like I said I just learned that word so
you know I'm practicing and you know
we'll get it right next time for sure
anyway
origen main comm that's where you can
get this stuff but we also have jeans
you know in the event of you not doing
jiu-jitsu at any point of the day where
some which is unfortunate well you know
yeah you know but we gotta be thankful
you know yeah you you get the by the way
I did a bad thing which was talk about
the Delta 68 jeans before they were
really you know ready to be released
maybe I got overexcited right maybe I
just lost my mind a little bit but I
will say this I have seen the Delta 68
jeans which are the most comfortable leg
garments ever created by man of any kind
are in production right now I think I've
said that before and I was inaccurate
the last time I said they're in
production it sounded cool but it was a
little bit of a like I was assuming I
made an assumption which we know is not
good the assumption was oh yeah they
must be in production by now they
weren't we were moving the fact we were
moving the boot line into the new
factory blah blah blah a bunch of things
were going on we weren't in production
yet guess what we are now we are in
production we are in production with
Delta 68 jeans and you claim that
they're the most comfortable leg garment
they not claimed I'm saying I have
warned every different type of leg
garment in my life
so the joggers these are the most
comfortable and the best more than the
Duggars yeah well I didn't really the
joggers aren't for me no and they don't
look normal yes and they don't feel more
this is my little theory hypothesis
whatever you put on the joggers he felt
the physical comfort but the
psychological and emotional discomfort
trumped it so I can't be the
front-runner of comfort soon saying I'm
gonna tell you no you're actually wrong
I will tell you the Delta 68 jeans are
as comfortable if not more comfortable
than the jogger syczyk Lee physically
more comfortable if I had to sleep in
one or the other I picked the jeans I'm
not
what do you call you're not gonna call
me a liar you're not gonna call you
later I'm not gonna refute your own
opinion so hey man all good but on a
factual level I'm just gonna say I don't
know a hundred percent if I agree with
you okay so there's two theoretical
presumptions that are being made by each
of us one of them is that these joggers
are the most comfortable like garments
ever not as functional by the way or
just as fun
no but the Delta 68 in my opinion of are
the most not only functional but also
most comfortable okay so there you go
there you go hey you know when we get
them we can see for ourselves
you know mm-hmm and if you want to get
em you get them from Orange in Maine Oh
Jimmy calm which is also where you can
get supplements yes supplements joint
supplements very important very
important joint supplements during
warfare krill super krill oil also
additional protein in the form of
dessert called monk also a version for
the warrior kids or you've kid milk many
different different flavors that's the
one you're gonna have to choose for
yourself
yep I'm not gonna say hey mint chocolate
is actually the best one well that's a
matter of opinion
it's not like the Delta 60 rice as a
matter of fact well questionable fact
we'll see this got that got talk of
white tea as well don't forget about
that the Jocko discipline in a go did
jock would discipline can it's so good
it's so good and it makes you feel
really good gets you up on step will say
right if you're gonna train if you
trained against a clone of yourself and
one of you had Jocko discipline go and
the other one didn't
the one with Jocko discipline go would
win a hundred percent of the day 100% of
the time no question am I wrong
double-blind though that's been tested
by the way oh yeah we can test that with
you and Jade twins you know
theoretically no but no your twins no
sorry boner ethically yes but I'll give
you know the Jocko discipline go
you'll go against Jay prove it'll be
proven for that that's it I can take all
this stuff up at origin made calm or you
the supplement stuff you can get at the
vitamin shop which is a retail outlet
all over the place and they're stocking
up if they were low on stock we're
taking care of that
they got stock now yes big time also
when you are getting your copy of two
who survived to the let I didn't know
this till the end - like the letter to T
wo who survived as opposed to what I
thought I thought it was like a letter
to who survived
you see I'm saying I like you like I
think okay I got it it was dedicated
kind of kind of situation anyway all
right - to serve who survived we go to
Jocko podcast.com click on the top where
it says books from the episodes boom we
got you so you can get it through there
easy way to just navigate him find it
also we have our own store it's called
chocolate store so you go to Jocko store
calm and this is where you can get more
rash guards represent the path while
you're doing your jujitsu or surfing or
whatever you use rash guards for some
guys and when they do powerlifting it
gives you all the range a little bit of
compression you know it's very
functional garment as it were you know I
have some t-shirts on there represent
the path discipline Eagles freedom the
attitude of good you know shirts
t-shirts hoodies light and heavy weight
laughs stuff on there if you like it if
you want something get something good
way to support as well also subscribe to
the podcast yes it's important to
subscribe to the podcast I guess mmm
varying levels of importance how about
that here's the deal
if you want to go ahead if you don't
want to continue to be lame that choice
is yours don't forget we also have the
grounded podcast which there's a new
episode out of the grounded podcast and
so you can get you can get just right up
to date on the ground and podcast we
also put warrior kid podcast because
let's face it
or your kids need more your podcasts so
we got that for them and also don't
forget about the you or your kids soap
from Irish Oaks ranch calm have you
gotten a have you got any killer soap
yes no no yes so for the hey well here's
the thing I just heard I was informed
yes that we they the the nice the great
people up at Irish Oaks ranch sent me
some and you some oh okay well let's
just make that a little clearer they
sent two bars to my house neither one of
those was labeled echo okay I'll just
put it to you like that
but I will say this killer soap is the
best soap ever and I'm not even kidding
it is so good it's it's everything I
ever could have imagined it is soap it's
a square most industrial looking bar
it's got a skull on it and it says
killer scope its killer soap and it's
black black soap yeah so yeah we and and
we're gonna sell it on our yep site so
so soon you'll be able to get Jacko's
soap you'll be able to get killer soap
made by a kid a warrior kid by the way
so there you go you know it's true also
we have a YouTube channel official get a
little check mark on our YouTube channel
by the way Brad that's something it's
not not did not I was not aware official
anyway not just you know okay that means
what it means but here's here's what it
actually means I have no idea what this
means
well sometimes people will they'll take
your content okay and they'll put it on
their YouTube channel which is you know
it spreads the words so that's cool but
you know sometimes if people want it
because there was a time where someone's
trying to kind of impersonate a little
bit oh yeah it could have been
misconstrued you know so people might
not be able to read right unless you get
check mark boom they know that's the
official one that's what the check mark
it so we're kind of in the game now yeah
yeah 100%
anyway a YouTube channel for the video
version of this podcast if you want to
see what Rose Schindler looks like yes
then you can check it out here you can
also see Ecco make some what he calls
enhanced videos they're visually
enhanced we don't know if it's
necessarily an improvement all the time
on reality mm-hm I kind of think it is
an improvement on reality of some things
I think sometimes echoes vision of the
world is a little bit better than
everyone then the normal vision of the
world just a little enhance why not if I
speak why not have things exploding
around me I think it works so there's
that they don't forget about
psychological warfare if you need a
little if you need a little
psychological hater then check out
psychological warfare it's on iTunes
Google Play mp3 check out flipside count
campus.com if you need a little visual
hitter to get you in the game Dakota
Meyer owns that listen em up on guys 115
get in the game with Dakota I've got
some books leadership strategy and
tactics Field Manual we got the way of
the warrior kid series we got Mikey and
the Dragons we got this one equals
freedom Field Manual we got extreme
ownership and the dichotomy leadership
these are all books that will help you
and the people around you be better and
win in life straight up all of them we
also have two who survived by rose and
max Schindler and also it's a capture
the stories captured by M Lee Connelly
but you can get that book as well it's
it's an outstanding read national on
front leadership consultancy what we do
is solve problems through leadership if
you listen to us talk about leadership
and you'd like to have help employing
these leadership strategies tactics and
principles inside your organization go
to a salon front calm that's what we do
we also have EF online which is online
interactive leadership training for you
for your organization go to EF
online.com to checked out check that out
we have a seminar a convention a
leadership course
[Music]
May 7 and 8 in Orlando September 16th
and 17th in Phoenix December 3rd and 4th
in Dallas go to extreme ownership comm
for details on that every event that
we've ever done has sold out so if you
want to come register early and of
course we have EF overwatch and EF
Legion EF overwatch executive leadership
from military for civilians EF Legion
frontline leadership frontline troops
with military experience to come to your
organization check out either one of
those EF overwatch comm or EF Legion
comm and if you want to connect with ROS
Schindler you can find her at her
website - who survived calm and on all
the social media outlets Twitter
Instagram and Facebook all of those
she's at - who survived and echo and I
are also on the interwebs on all the
various social media channels including
YouTube where we are now official echo
is at Echo Charles I am at Chaco Willick
and the YouTube channel is called Jaco
podcast and to mrs. Rose Schindler once
again thank you for for coming on and
sharing your incredible story which is
just it's even to sit here and hear you
say over and over again that's
unbelievable it's unbelievable and it
reminds us of what what it means to
suffer what it means to face
unimaginable Horrors and still maintain
hope and while we will not dwell we
certainly will not forget and to the
military service members out there that
have fought and continued to fight to
protect the weak to liberate the
enslaved to bring the light
of freedom into the world like those
forces that liberated the concentration
camps thank you all for your service and
the same goes to our police and law
enforcement to our firefighters and
paramedics and EMTs and dispatchers and
correctional officers and Border Patrol
and Secret Service you all also make
sacrifices to protect us and we thank
you for that and everyone else out there
you know clearly we have seen today
through roses story once again that
human beings are capable of absolutely
horrific and hideous evil but we've also
seen that human beings are capable of
overcoming those satanic forces in the
world and of maintaining hope against
the darkness and in the end we can win
we can win so fight on do the right
thing and no matter what do not give up
hope and that's all we've got for
tonight so until next time this is echo
and Jocko